GOOD MORNING OF WELCOME TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY.
M. WILL WAY TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AT IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE
GOING TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
SINCE MISS
QUIRK IS HERE.
WISH.
FOR THE FIRST ONE.
EVER GONNA HEAR FROM MS DOCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER. WORKGROUP
STARS A SUBCOMMITTEE AS SOON AS
WE.
HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL VOTE.
I LATE ITEM TWENTY FOUR.
AB TWO TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
CALIFORNIA TUITION FOR WOMEN
MALE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS.
THANK YOU OF GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
TWENTY FIVE IFTY A BILL
RECOGNIZING THE HUMANITY OF
WOMEN IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND I ACCEPT ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES AND AMENDMENTS.
MANY OF OUR FOR AN I AM MUCH
REFER A.
VISITORS ARE HERE TODAY BUT IF
THEY ARE THAT'S FINE WE WILL
COMPLETE SEAT. UP MANY OF OUR
PRISON POLICIES ARE DESIGNED FOR
MEN IN MIND AND DO NOT REFLECT
WOMEN'S NEEDS.
WOMEN ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
POPULATION UNFORTUNATELY BEHIND
BARS AT A RATE THAT FAR EXCEEDS
INCARCERATED MEN.
AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY MORE
THAN EIGHTY SIX PERCENT OF WOMEN
LOCKED UP ARE SURVIVORS OF
PHYSICAL. UP PAST PHYSICAL AND
SEXUAL ABUSE.
ACCORDING TO THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR WOMEN HAS SUICIDE RATES FOUR
TO FIVE TIMES THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE FOR ALL PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN FEMALE STATE
PRISONS. FROM TWENTY TWELVE TO
TWENTY SIXTEEN WOMEN COMPRISE
FOUR PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRISON POPULATION BUT ACCOUNT
FOR ELEVEN PERCENT OF SUICIDES.
SEARCHES WHILE DESIGNED TO
PROMOTE SAFETY ARE OFTEN
POWERFUL RIM REMINDERS OF
TRAUMA.
IN THESE INSTANCES IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE REQUIRE TRAUMA
INFORMED PRACTICES.
WOMEN CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
PERFORM THESE SEARCHES CAN
MAXIMIZE FEELINGS OF PHYSICAL
SEXUAL EMOTIONAL AND RELATIONAL
SAFETY FOR WOMEN.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PUT REDUCE
THE POTENTIAL THAT STAFF ACTIONS
WILL TRAUMATIZE A RE TRAUMATIZED
PEOPLE IN WOMEN'S PRISONS BY
PROHIBITING MAIL OFF
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. FROM PAT
DOWN SEARCHES BEING IN VIEW OF
OR RETURNING INTO AN AREA WHERE
INCARCERATED WOMEN. ARE IN A
STATE OF UNDRESS SUCH A SHOWER
ROOMS AND BATHROOMS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF EMERGENCY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS TO HOLD
CORRECTION OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE
ENSURE THE DOCUMENTATION IS
SUBMITTED WHEN WOMEN ARE PET
SEARCHED ARE SEEN IN A STATE OF
UNDRESS BY MAIL. OFF A MALE
GUARDS
THIS COMMONSENSE BILL ALIGNS
CALIFORNIA'S PENAL CODE WOULD
BEST PRACTICES AND THE FEDERAL
PRISON RAPE ELIMINATION ACT.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SCOTT IS
SPONSORED BY CUTS THE CUTS IF I
MEAN HAS TAX CUT FIFTY AND THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
SUPPORT AND SUPPORTED BY THE
ACLU. ARE ALL LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE.
I'M NOT SURE OF ME OUT TO
MIDNIGHT IS HERE WHO WAS FROM
THE COMMUNITY GAZE WHAT
DIRECTOR.
OF FOR A HAS TECH COULD FIFTY.
AND JESSICA JACKSON SLOANE FROM
THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR ALSO OF
HAS TAKEN FIFTY I'M NOT SURE IF
THEY HERE YET. OF THEY'RE NOT
HERE YET SO.
YOU.
OKAY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BUILD A
PLACE HERE REPRESENTING CUT
FIFTY I APOLOGIZE A OUR PEOPLE
MIGHT'VE GOTTEN. CAUGHT UP IN
THE TRAFFIC.
THIS BILL EXCELLENT BILL AND
IT'S PART OF A NATIONAL PROGRAM
THAT.
SEEKS TO.
ADDRESS A VERY SPECIFIC PROBLEM
AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE OTHER.
OTHER DIRECTIONS OF THIS CAN GO.
IN THE FUTURE OF OTHER
LEGISLATION BUT.
.
WE FEEL THIS IS A VERY VALUABLE.
VERY VALUABLE BILL AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH CDC ARE TO
MAKE SURE THAT EXIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE COVERED.
THAT WOULD BE THINGS FOR
INSTANCE.
.
EMINENT ESCAPE A RISK
DISASSOCIATED STAFF OR TO.
INMATE.
AND I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAKE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
THANK YOU CUT FIFTY FOUR.
SPONSORING A BILL.
DR WEBER YOU MAY CLOSE YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
HUMANITY IN THE WOMEN'S WHEN
WOMEN BEHIND BARS AND MOVE FOR
WITH COMPASSION AND TREATMENT.
I'M GRATEFUL THAT CUT OF THAT
HAS TECH AT FIFTY ABOUT THIS
ISSUE FOR IS ONE OF THE FIRST
ISSUES OBVIOUSLY THE LOOKING AT
A NUMBER OF ISSUES RELATED TO
WOMEN IN PRISON. BUT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE OF BILL THAT
BASICALLY MOST OF US WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
SAFETY. AND DOUSED HOPEFULLY
SECURITY FOR THE WOMEN WHO ARE
INCARCERATED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME I BOTH AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY.
OKAY DOT WEBER AND.
THIS BILL ENJOYS A A AND I
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
AND OF ONCE WE GET.
QUORUM.
WILL BE ABLE TO.
AND.
WE WOULD VOTE ON A.
DEL ONLY THING I'M I'M SORRY DO
WE HEAR FROM ALL YOUR YOUR
WITNESSES I THINK THAT WOULD BE
GOOD FOR EVERYBODY THEIR EUROPA
VERY INTERESTING WOMEN WHO ARE
STRONG ADVOCATES AND I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT. YOUR
ACTION THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE AYE BUT WHEN YOU GOT A
QUORUM. THANK YOU HAVE MY WHAT
MICHAEL LOT THIS HERE MISTER
LET.
THE SUREST.
NEXT IS.
.
MISTER GLORIA.
TODD.
AB TWENTY ONE.
BOTH THREE.
GOOD MORNING SHARON GOOD MORNING
I AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
BRING BEFORE YOU TODAY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH
THREE. COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION
TO ESTABLISH MINIMUM STANDARDS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO CARRY
A LOADED CONCEALED WEAPON.
YOU MAY KNOW THAT UNDER CURRENT
LAW PERSON WAS NEVER EVEN FIRED
A GUN OR RECEIVE PROPER TRAINING
ON HOW TO SAFELY HANDLE ONE CAN
RECEIVE A CONCEALED CARRY
PERMIT.
FROM A LOCAL JURISDICTION AND IN
LEGALLY CARRY A LOADED FIREARM
IN PUBLIC.
I BELIEVE IT'S PUTS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AT RISK.
AS THESE DEADLY WEAPONS COULD
IT UP THE WRONG AN UNTRAINED
HANDS.
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AB TWENTY
ONE OH THREE ESTABLISHES SOME
COMMON SENSE STANDARDS FOR
CONCEALED CARRY APPLICANTS.
FIRST A BETWEEN ONE OF THREE
WOULD REQUIRE ALL TRAINING
COURSES CURRENT CURRENTLY
REQUIRED FOR CONCEALED WEAPON
LICENCES TO BE AT LEAST EIGHT
HOURS IN LENGTH.
WELL STATE LAW CURRENTLY
ESTABLISHES A MAXIMUM OF SIXTEEN
HOURS FOR THE TRAINING COURSES
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO MINIMUM. WE
BELIEVE IN EIGHT HOURS.
ACQUIREMENT IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT LICENSING AUTHORITIES OF
ALREADY REQUIRE FOR CONCEALED
CARRY PERMITS AND IN MUCH
CALIFORNIA.
SECONDLY AB TWENTY ONE A THREE
REQUIRES CONCEAL CARRY
APPLICANTS TO DISTRICT TO
DEMONSTRATE SAFE HANLEY
PROFICIENCY ON A FIRING RANGE.
AGAIN WITH THIS PROVISION WE ARE
CODIFIED BEST PRACTICES DRAWING
HEAVILY FROM WHAT LOCAL
LICENSING AUTHORITIES GENERALLY
REQUIRE.
HOWEVER IN THIS CASE WE ARE
WHERE AT LEAST ONE LICENSING
AUTHORITY DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
LIVE FIRE TRAINING.
IN MY MIND THAT COULD THAT COULD
HAVE THE PERSON.
BEEP AUTHORIZED TO CARRY A
CONCEALED PERMIT IN A WEAPON IN
PUBLIC WITHOUT DEMONSTRATE
PROFICIENCY. A WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER.
LASTLY RECENT ADMINISTERED AB
TWENTY ONE OR THREE REQUIRE
LOCAL LICENSING AUTHORITIES TO
DEVELOP SPECIFIC LIVE FIRING
PROFICIENCY STANDARDS TO MAKE
THOSE STANDARDS AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. WE BELIEVE AT THIS
PROVISION IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
RIGOROUS UNIFORM STANDARDS AMONG
TRAINING PROGRAMS WHILE THE SAME
TIME MAINTAINING LOCAL CONTROL.
TO PUT THIS BILL IN PERSPECTIVE
CALIFORNIA REQUIRES APPLICANTS
FOR DRIVERS LICENSES TO
DEMONSTRATE BEHIND THE WHEEL
PROFICIENCY OF A VEHICLE BEFORE
THE DMV WILL ISSUE A LICENSE.
YES STATE LAW FEELS PRESCRIBE
SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS FOR
CONCEALED CARRY WEAPONS THAT IS
WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY.
AS MENTIONED MOST SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL LICENSING
AUTHORITIES RD ADOPT SIMILAR
KINDS OF PROVISIONS IN THE LOCAL
POLICIES AND WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT.
THAT IS WHY AB ONE A WEEK AB
TWENTY ONE OR THREE IS SO
NECESSARY WE MUST ESTABLISH A
FLOOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
STANDARDS DON'T FALL BELOW IT.
AS THEY DO IN OTHER STATES
I'M PROUD TO COUNT THE
CALIFORNIA SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE INEQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AMONG THEM WITNESSED
OF MANY SUPPORTERS OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEACM THIS MORNING WE ARE WITH
ITS SHARES INDULGENCE I HAVE
THREE WITNESSES WHO WILL AGREE
TO SPLIT THEIR TIME AND IT HERE
TO THE COMMITTEES LONG STANDING
AND VERY WISE RULES.
DAVID BRAIN OF ROCKLAND A
FATHER HUSBAND AND NO ARMY
VETERAN GUN OWNER AND SUPPORTER
OF COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS GUN VIOLENCE IN AMERICA.
I'D JONES OUT KAZERUN IAN.
SEE I DON'T PARTISAN NOW LOS
ANGELES AREA AYE DANVILLE.
RESIDENT A MOM AN EDUCATOR IN
THE LEAD BUT LOCALLY FOR MOMS
DEMAND ACTION FOR GODS AND.
CPO COUNTY MANY OF YOU MAY
RECOGNIZE RICHARD A WITNESS TEAR
A TIRELESS ADVOCACY FOR GUN
SAFETY LEGISLATION FOLLOWING THE
TRAGIC DEATH OF HIS SON
CHRISTOPHER WHO WAS KILLED IN
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN. ISLA VISTA
RAMPAGE ALTERED OVER TO MY
WITNESSES NO COULD YOU JUST WE
WANT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHAT
WE HAVE MEMBERS HERE AND THEN
WE'LL GET RIGHT TO YOUR
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU SIR MAN FACTOR.
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
CARDIO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER KILEY.
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
QUORUM IS PRESENT YOU MAKE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICHARD MARTINEZ.
BUT I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE MY
SON CHRISTOPHER IS DEAD.
SHOT AND KILLED IN ISLA VISTA
CALIFORNIA ON MAY TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY FOURTEEN.
CHRIS WAS A STUDENT AT UC SANTA
BARBARA JUST TWENTY YEARS OLD.
HE WAS OUR ONLY CHILD AND HE WAS
THE CENTER OF OUR LIVES.
HE WAS EVERYTHING TO US.
NOTHING THAT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME
BEFORE CHRIS WAS KILLED IS
IMPORTANT TO ME NOW.
THE ONLY THING THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO ME NOW IS THE WORK THAT I DO
TO TRY TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE IN
OUR COUNTRY.
I DON'T WANT ANOTHER FAMILY TO
EXPERIENCE OUR LOS.
AS AMERICANS AND CALIFORNIANS WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PREVENT TO PROTECT OUR FAMILIES
BY ADOPTING COMMON SENSE
MEASURES. CONSISTENT WITH THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
TO REDUCE IT INJURIES GUN
INJURIES AND DEATH.
I'M HERE WITH YOU TODAY TO
SUPPORT A COMMON SENSE GUN
SAFETY MEASURE THAT WILL HELP
PROTECT OUR FAMILIES.
AB TWENTY ONE OH THREE WOULD
REQUIRE PEOPLE WITH CONCEALED
CARRY LICENSES TO COMPLETE LIVE
FIRE SAFETY TRAINING BEFORE.
THEY CAN CARRY A CONCEALED
LOADED GUN IN PUBLIC.
AS THE U. S. ARMY VETERAN I KNOW
THE IMPORTANCE OF LIVE FIRE
SAFETY TRAINING.
I'VE TRAINED WITH THE M.
SIXTEEN.
FORTY FIVE CALIBER HANDGUN
SHOTGUN AND M. SIXTY MACHINE
GUN.
TWENTY FIVE STATES HAVE THIS
REQUIREMENT AND CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT.
WE SHOULD DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WHO ARE LICENSED TO CARRY
CONCEALED LOADED GUNS IN OUR
STATE ARE PREPARED TO DO SO
SAFELY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO SUPPORT
OF BELT TWENTY ONE NO THREE
REQUIRING LIVE FIRE TRAINING FOR
CONCEALED CARRY PERMITS IN OUR
STATE. MY NAME IS JOAN BECAUSE
IRANIAN BY BACKGROUND IS IN
EDUCATION AND CHILDHOOD TRAUMA.
I'M A CO LEADER OF CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER MOMS DEMAND ACTION FOR
GUN SENSE IN AMERICA AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I AM A MOM.
I GOT INVOLVED IN GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AFTER THE ISLA VISTA
SHOOTINGS BECAUSE IT COULD HAVE
EASILY BEEN MY DAUGHTER. AS SHE
WAS THEY'RE GOING TO SCHOOL.
INSTEAD. IT WAS HER PEERS LIKE
CHRISTOPHER RICHARDSON WHO WERE
TRAGICALLY SHOT AND KILLED THAT
HORRIFIC EVENING.
ALL BECAUSE OF A YOUNG MAN THAT
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAD A GUN IN
THE FIRST PLACE BECAUSE AT THAT
TIME WE DID NOT HAVE A SAFETY
LINE PLACE LIKE OUR CURRENT GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER. THAT
WOULD HAVE GIVEN A MECHANISM TO
THE SHOOTERS FAMILY AS WELL AS
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I AM PROUD THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LEADER ON GUN SAFETY LAWS
BUT UNLIKE TWENTY FIVE OTHER
STATES WE DO NOT HAVE A LAW
REQUIRING LIVE. FIRE TRAINING
FOR PEOPLE PERMITTED TO CARRY
AHEAD AND LOADED GUN IN PUBLIC.
AMENDED THE LAW TO REQUIRE THE
LIFE RIGHT FIRE TRAINING FOR
CONCEALED CARRY WOULD
MEMORIALIZE AND PRESERVE A
POLICY THAT CALIFORNIA SHARES
AND POLICE CHIEFS HAVE RT
ADOPTED AND WANT.
ADDING A LIVE FIRE TRAINING
REQUIREMENT INTO STATE STATUE
WOULD INSURE THAT THIS COMMON
SENSE REQUIREMENT CONTINUES TO
BE CONSISTENTLY APPLIED ACROSS
THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ONE A THREE.
I AM A FATHER ARMY VETERAN BOY
SCOUT LEADER.
AND A GUN OWNER.
I'VE GROWN UP AROUND GUNS FROM A
YOUNG AGE I'VE RECEIVED AND
PROVIDED FIREARM SAFETY
TRAINING.
I NEVER GO SHOOTING WITH
SOMEONE.
UNLESS I KNOW THEY KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE A WEAPON.
I RECENTLY TOOK MY KIDS OUT TO
THE SPENCERVILLE FIRING RANGE ON
BLM LAND NOW OUT NEAR SMARTS
WILL.
THERE WAS A YOUNG LADY WITH HER
BOYFRIEND SHOOTING ASSAULT STYLE
WEAPONS A CLAY PIGEONS.
I'M MORE THAN ONE OCCASION SHE
SWUNG THE MUZZLE. TOWARDS US AND
OTHER SHOOTERS.
SHE DID NOT REGULARLY PUT THE
WEAPON ON SAFE AND HAS OBVIOUSLY
NOT PREPARED TO HANDLE THAT
WEAPON.
WE GOT THE HECK OUT OF THERE
FAST.
JUST IMAGINE IF YOU HAD A SMALL
HANDGUN.
LOCKED AND LOADED READY TO GO
CONCEALED CARRIED BY SOMEONE WHO
HASN'T DEMONSTRATED THE ABILITY
TO SAFELY HANDLE A GUN. ONLY
THAT THEY CAN PAY A FEE AND
ANSWERS OF QUESTIONS
AND THEN SHOVES IT IN THE OTHER
POCKET THEIR PURSE THEIR
BACKPACK THEIR GLOVE
COMPARTMENT.
WHAT CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION
REQUIRING BACKGROUND CHECKS
BEFORE BEING ABLE TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM AND ALSO REQUIRE SAFETY
CLASSES BEFORE PERSON CAN CARRY
A GUN IN PUBLIC? THERE IS NO
PROOF OF PRACTICE REQUIRED.
THANKFULLY MOSHARRAF CYBER
PRACTICE OF REQUIRING A PERSON
TO SHOW THAT THEY CAN SAFELY
HANDLE LOAD DISCHARGE CLEAR AND
RETURN A WEAPON TO SAFE.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS A UNIFORM REQUIREMENT ACROSS
THE STATE.
IF WE'RE GOING. TO CONTINUE TO
LEAD THE NATION IN GOOD COMMON
SENSE APPROACHES TO GUN SAFETY
WE MUST REQUIRE POTENTIAL COULD
SEE CONCEALED CARRY OWNERS.
PROVE THAT THEY CAN OPERATE A
FIREARM SAFELY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
PAYMENT ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE.
AMANDA WILCOX HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LUIS LOPEZ MOMS DEMAND ACTION
FOLSOM IN SUPPORT.
Q. MAP.
KENDRA BANDS MOMS DEMAND ACTION
BACK OF CALIFORNIA.
I SUPPORT.
CLAIRE AUGUST MOMS DEMAND ACTION
FAIR OAKS CALIFORNIA.
CYNTHIA SHALLOT MOST ACTION
SACRAMENTO.
IN SUPPORT.
ROSEMARY YOSHIKAWA MOMS DEMAND
ACTION SACRAMENTO CHAPTER WE'RE
IN SUPPORT.
UNDER ADD TARKA US MOMS DEMAND
ACTION IN FOLSOM. IN SUPPORT.
JUDY COLLINS DANVILLE CALIFORNIA
MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND I
SUPPORT.
CLAIRE SENTIENT AUTHOR FRANCISCO
MONTHS DEMAND ACTION EVERY TOWN
SURVIVOR NETWORK MOTHER OF
COMMUNAL SHOT WITH A GUN TWO
THOUSAND AND. FOURTEEN I
SUPPORT.
KAREN ROBUST MONTHS DEMAND
ACTION FOLSOM I SUPPORT.
NICHOLS SU MOM'S A MAN ACTION
DANVILLE I SUPPORT.
HORRIFY LIQUID GIVE ITS LAW
CENTER TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
ALSO SUPPORT.
WHEN NATIONALLY YOU THE LIVE
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
MY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COURCELLES ALONE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EACHERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
FLORA PART BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY HAVE TO MAKE A LITTLE
ROOM.
YOUR NETWORK.
THE MORE IN GENERAL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ HERE ON BEHALF THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION TODAY.
WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL IS A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH FOR PROBLEM.
CCW HOLDERS ACROSS THE NATION
AND IN CALIFORNIA OR SOME THE
MOST LAW ABIDING CITIZENS OUT
THERE.
AND TAKE.
CARRYING A FIREARM VERY
SERIOUSLY WE HAVE SOME VERY
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA REGARDS TO TRAINING.
I'M CURRENTLY A PERSON WHO
WISHES TO OBTAIN CCW A MASCOT
THEIR EXTENSIVE PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES.
TRAINING THAT IS ANYWHERE FROM
EIGHT TO SIXTEEN HOURS THAT IS
VERY COMPREHENSIVE.
AND.
THE FOLKS TODAY'S OBVIOUSLY ON
LIVE FIRE IN MOSHE ARENS DO
REQUIRE LIVE FIRE.
OR SPECIFIC TRAINERS AND IT'S
GONNA GO INTO THEIR CHORUS CREEK
CURRICULUM. WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE GOING TO REQUIRE IT BUT
WHEN YOU'RE SITTING IN A
CLASSROOM FOR SIXTEEN HOURS.
THERE'S A LOT OF MATERIALS THAT
ARE COVERED ARE WERE UNAWARE OF
ANY ANY PROBLEMS WITH LACK OF
TRAINING CURRENTLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. TIME ONE THING I
FORGOT TO MENTION IN THE
REQUIREMENTS IS EVERY TWO YEARS.
PERSON WISHING TO RENEW THEIR
PERMIT IT'S GONNA HAVE TO GO
BACK.
NOW DUE TO LACK OF TRAINING OR
LACK A LIVE FIRE AND WE FEEL
THIS IS SOLUTIONS ARE FOR PROM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CRADLE IS ABOUT THE FIRES POLICY
COALITION ALEKO THE THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE. A.
REALLY AS WE'RE LOOKING FOR
QUOTE UNQUOTE COMMON SENSE
FIREARMS LEGISLATION.
MIKE MY CONCERN IS ONCE AGAIN
THE WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS
THAT SOLVE A PROBLEM AND I'VE
YET. I'VE YOU HAVE YET TO HEAR
ONE PERSON BRING UP ONE INCIDENT
WHERE YOU WHERE A CCW HOLDERS.
AYE HAS BEEN INVOLVED A IN IN
WHERE'D WHERE'D LACK OFTRAINING
OF A CCW HOLDER HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN ANY INCIDENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SINCE.
AS FAR AS I KNOW NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE WHEN CCW FOR FIRST STARTED
STARTED BEING ISSUED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I I BELIEVE THAT IF WE ARE GOING
TO LOOK TO SOLVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE ISSUE OF VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY UP PERHAPS WE
ABIDING CITIZENS BUT MAYBE WE
SHOULD ACTUALLY START.
LOOKING AT OUR POLICIES
RELATING TO A RELEASING THOSE
FROM.
FROM INCARCERATION WHO HAVE
PROVEN TO BE VIOLENT OUR
SOCIETIES WITH THAT THESE
CONCERNS THAT WE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST
WONDERING I'M GONNA CALIFORNIA I
KNOW THERE'S A VERY LONG LINE
OUT THERE I MEAN SAM WAS
SEPARATE AS WITH GUN OWNER IT
WAS GOING TO BE HERE IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL.
I WAS HOPING YOU COULD MAKE IT
AND HE IS A TRAINER.
AND HAD SOME REALLY GOOD INSIDE
AND I'M SURE HE ACT THAT
NEWSLETTER SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS
THE QUIRK.
BOB I JUST LIKE TO MENTION THAT
OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE PEOPLE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS HAVE BEEN KILLED BY
CONCEALED CARRY.
HOLDERS ARE ABOUT HALF OF THOSE
BY SUICIDE I DO THINK THEY NEED
MORE TRAINING.
AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BELL.
AND I'LL SECOND.
I'VE.
GOOD MISTER KILEY.
I THINK U. SO I WAS RECORDED YOU
KNOW AND YOU KNOW HOW MANY.
SHE COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICES
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE THE SORT
REQUIREMENTS NOW.
SO WE HAVE. YOUR WHERE POLICE
ONE COUNTY THAT EXPLICITLY
REFERENCES NOT REQUIRING ANY
SPECIFIC TRAINING THAT'S GLENN
COUNTY.
WERE ALSO IN TO HAMMER VENTURA
AND SOLANO COUNTY THERE'S NO
EXPLICIT MENTION OF REQUIRING
LIVE FIRE TRAINING. TIME JUST
APPROVED LIST OF TRAINERS OF SO
THERE'S SOME DISPARITIES BETWEEN
COUNTIES WHICH IS WHAT THIS
BILLS ATTEMPTING TO RECTIFY.
I SAY I'M IN CLASS BECAUSE OF
THE OPPOSITION IF.
IF SOMEONE WANTS TO RETURN.
JUST TO HELP ME UNDERSTAND SO
IF THIS IS SORT OF ALREADY
REFLECTIVE OF EXISTING PRACTICE
YOU SEE ANY. PARTICULAR HARM.
FROM HAVING THE STATE. COME IN
AND AND REGULATE THIS MORE IF IT
IS MERELY REFLECTING EXISTING
PRACTICE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THROUGH YOU TO
MISTER KILEY A COULD YOU REPEAT
YOUR QUESTION PLEASE YES SO I
THINK IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU SAID
THAT THIS IS THAT YOU KNOW MORE
AWESOME LINE WITH WHAT I. YOU
KNOW I SEE CW COURSES ALREADY
INTEL I DID YOU SEE ANY ACTIVE
HARM FROM THE STATE COMING IN IN
REGULATING AND AWAY THAT RT
REFLECTS.
EXISTING PRACTICE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THROUGH YOU TO
MISTER KILEY. READ RIGHT NOW
THAT WHAT WE'VE HEARD IS A
PRESUMPTION THAT THIS IS THE
ONLY TRAINING THAT SOMEONE.
WHO'S GETTING A CCW MIGHT TAKE.
OR EVEN IT ANY HANDLING AND
MOST CCW HOLDERS THAT I KNOW.
.
TO DATE THEY TAKE OTHER COURSES
THERE. REGULARLY OUT FIRING
RANGE EXCITER.
AND AGAIN.
THERE'S.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WE HAVE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS SOME STATES.
HAVE EVERYTHING FROM PERMIT WAS
CARRY.
OTHER STATES WITH PERMITS.
DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC MENTION
OR SPECIFIC MINIMUMS WHEN IT
COMES TO A.
TO THE SPECIFIC TRAINING.
WHETHER IT INVOLVES.
.
LEGAL ASPECTS OR OR CERTAIN
COURSES A PIRATE CETERA. AND SO.
.
WE JUST DON'T FEEL THAT THIS IS
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM WE
HAVE NOT BEEN PRESENTED WITH ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS AN
EXISTING PROBLEM.
AND SO THAT SEACM A PROPOSITION
I SEE A SET OF GOD AND.
TIED TO THE A TO THE MEMBERS TO
THE THROUGH THE CHAIR. YEAH I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT I
UNDERSTAND THAT OUT ONE BECAUSE
THERE IS NO THERE IS NO REAL
PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED.
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT I THINK THE OTHER ISSUE IS.
A WHEN HAS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR THIS BODY
NOT SOUGHT TO ONCE IT STARTS
REGULATING TO INCREASE THAT
REGULATION TO CHANGE THAT
REGULATION AND THE ONE THING
THAT WE'VE SEEN COMING IN
PARTICULAR FROM THIS BODY IS THE
FACT THAT. THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NO PROBLEM REGULATING US
SOMETHING WITH WHICH THEY HAVE
VERY LITTLE KNOWLEDGE OR
UNDERSTANDING. AND THAT THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS ONCE
AGAIN YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
REGULATIONS EVENTUALLY PUT IN
PLACE A THAT HAVE NO BEARING IN
REALITY OR UNDERSTANDING OF. A
OF CONCEALED CARRY PERMITS OR OF
FIREARMS OR THE FIREARM INDUSTRY
OR CULTURE. A.
I AND UNFORTUNATELY I WOULD
NORMALLY I WOULD NOT DESCRIBE
MAIENSCHEIN WE'RE NOT SUBSCRIBE
TO THE SLIPPERY SLOPE THEORY BUT
I THINK THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IS PROOF POSITIVE
WHEN IT COMES TO FIREARMS THAT
THAT IS IN FACT THE CASE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MISTER ARE
GONNA HOW YOU RESPOND TO SORT OF
THAT THAT THE POINT OF HEARING
IS A SOLUTION. SEARCH OF A
PROBLEM I MEAN THERE SEEMS TO BE
SOME CONSENSUS THAT THIS MORE
LAST REFLECTS EXISTING PRACTICE
MAYBE THERE'S SOME COUNTY BID ON
SOME OF THE ROLE OF RELIGION.
PROBLEMS THERE I I DO THINK THAT
THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS KIND ON
YOU.
TO SHOWED EVIDENCE THAT.
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING IS A NEW
LAW WILL?
CHANGE EXISTING PRACTICES IN A
WAY THAT ACTUALLY IMPROVES GUN
SAFETY SO WHAT'S YOUR EVIDENCE
THAT WILL ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
OF.
THE EVENING NEWS EVERY DAY
MISTER KILEY THAT EVERY
NEWSPAPER. WHAT HAPPENED THIS
MORNING IN MARYLAND I MEAN FOR
SOMEONE TO SIT BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND SUGGESTED THERE IS
NOT A PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY
WITH GUNS? THEY'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION NOW WITH REGARD TO
THIS SPECIFIC PIECE OF
LEGISLATION MISTER KILEY WE DO
HAVE DIFFERENT COUNTIES WITH
DIFFERENT WAYS OF OPERATING.
AND IT WAS SUGGESTED PERHAPS
ADVOCATES OF THIS BILL HAVE NO.
EXPERTISE SIR.
EXPERIENCE WITH GUNS I WAS ON
THE RIGHT FOOTING A.
IN WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL I WE
WENT EXTENSIVE TRAINING A BEFORE
WE WERE ALLOWED TO BE ON.
THE FIRING RANGE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS NOT
TO SAY THE CASE IN EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY IN SO I MUCH LIKE WE HAVE
AS A BODY CHOSEN TO REGULATE.
THE USE OF A VEHICLES ON OUR
STREETS WHICH ARE DEADLY WEAPONS
SO IS A CONCEALED LOADED GUN IN
PUBLIC AND SO WE SHOULD
ESTABLISH A MINIMUM TRAINING
REQUIREMENT THERE IS CURRENTLY A
MAXIMUM. THERE IS NO MINIMUM AND
WE CAN DO THAT.
AND LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY
IT'S NOT JUST HIS BODY AT THE
TIME TO DEREGULATE THIS AS YOU
WELL KNOW MISTER KILEY THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED ADDITIONAL
GUNS SAFETY LEGISLATION. IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION SO IT
ISN'T JUST US THAT'S DOING THIS
WERE RESPONDING TO THE WHAT THE
WILL AND DESIRES OF THE VOTERS
CALIFORNIA.
THANK OKAY I THINK I'M AT THAT
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT THERE DOES
NEED TO BE SOME SORT OF TRAINING
THAT GOES INTO IT THE QUESTION
IS YOU KNOW WHAT IS THAT GOING
TO ENTAIL AND SO. THAT MY HOPE
WOULD BE THAT WE'D HAVE SOME
REASON FOR THE PARTICULAR
REQUIREMENTS WE'RE GONNA SET
FORTH IN STATURE RATHER THAN
JUST SAYING THAT THESE.
YES SOME PRETTY GOOD SO DO YOU
YOU KNOW IS HAS THERE AT IS THIS
EVEN STUDIED AND SHOWN A CAVE
YOU HAVE THESE REQUIREMENTS IN
PLACE THEN THERE'LL BE A. AN
INCREASE IN GUN SAFETY.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL WAS CRAFTED
WITH LOOKING AT THE BEST
PRACTICES OF JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE ESTABLISHED TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND AND HAVE WORKED
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO ESTABLISH THAT I
THINK WHAT WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD
AGAIN IS REFLECTIVE OF WHAT MANY
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY
DO. I WEAR ESTABLISHING THE
FLOOR FOR WHICH ALL COUNTIES
HAVE TO OPERATE ON NOT JUST THE
ONES THAT I THINK ARE GOOD
ACTORS IN TRYING TO ENGAGE IN
THIS IN A SENSIBLE WAY.
OKAY AND INSIDE IS MY LAST
QUESTION AND I STILL HAVEN'T
REALLY SEEN ANY EVIDENCE LINKING
THESE BIGGER PRACTICES THEN
PROVE GOOD GUN SAFETY IS THERE
ANY. PLACE I COULD FIND THAT
SOMETIMES FOLKS ARE ENCOURAGED
NOT TO SEE WHAT'S BEFORE THEIR
OWN EYES AND WHAT WE HAVE IS A
GUN SAFETY CHALLENGE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO CARRY A LOADED
WEAPON IN PUBLIC. THE SHOULD
HAVE SOME TRAINING WITH WITH
REGARD TO THAT AYE THEA THINK WE
SPECIFICALLY ASKING IS CAN WE
PROVE IN THE COUNTIES WHERE A%
MINIMUM STANDARD HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THAT THOSE COUNTY
SOMEHOW HAVE FEWER OF GUN
VIOLENCE SUCH.
SITUATIONS.
AYE WE CAN WORK ON THAT MISTER
KILEY AS YOU WELL KNOW THIS IS
THE FIRST HEARING FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I IMAGINE WE'RE
GOING TO A LOT OF WORK RESPOND A
LOT OF MEMBERS OF QUESTIONS.
WILL WORK ON THAT AND I THINK
THAT THE SHERIFF'S IN THOSE
LOCAL OFFICIALS ESTABLISH THOSE
THOSE MINIMUMS BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT WAS WHAT
WAS. WOULD IMPROVE SAFETY IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND I I'M A
STAND WITH THE SHERIFF'S AYE IN
THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS WITH
REGARD TO THAT.
* FOR ON THAT ON THAT ON
THAT ISSUE. THANK YOU.
MISTER QUIRK JUST TO ANSWER%
MISTER KYLIE'S QUESTION. IF YOU
LOOK AT CALIFORNIA VERSUS
FLORIDA PLACE ONE PLACE WITH
STRICT GUN CONTROLS ONE WITH
NOT.
WHAT YOU SEE IN FLORIDA AND
PARTICULAR IS MORE UNINTENTIONAL
CHILDREN?
BECAUSE PEOPLE REALLY HAVEN'T
BEEN TRAINED ARE WE WHICH A
PREDOMINANTLY IN CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE ARE TRAINED AND I THINK
THERE'S GOOD EVIDENCE THAT THAT
HELPS.
EVEN IF IT'S NOT EVERY COUNTY
THANK YOU.
I MISTER.
GLORIA I WAS JUST WHAT CLOSING
TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE TO MY
COLLEAGUES A QUESTION IN
WISCONSIN SINCE MANDATORY A
HONEY SAFETY TRAINING COURSES
HAVE BEEN ACQUIRED THERE HAS
BEEN A SUBSTANTIAL DECLINE IN
FATAL AND NONFATAL INCIDENTS.
DURING THE STATE'S ANNUAL DEER
HUNTING SEASON MAYBE APPLES AND
ORANGES BUT SINCE THE TRAINING
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF THE FATALITY.
OF THE USE OF THESE WEAPONS I
WILL GET YOU SOME MORE
INFORMATION EVERY MEMBER THIS
COMMITTEE I SHOULD BE FULL
INFORMED IN THE DECISION MAKING
IT THEY HAVE.
BY THINK COMMON SENSE INTUITION
SAYS THAT IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
ALLOWED TO GO ON PUBLIC WITH A
LOADED GUN YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
APPROVED PROFICIENCY AND ALIVE
OUR SITUATION. IT'S COMMON SENSE
IT IS WORTHY OF YOUR SUPPORT ASK
WHEN IVA.
THANK YOU AND DUBBED.
IF YOU NOTICED THIS.
JUST DISCUSSION.
.
REALLY KIND OF INTERESTING.
I I HAVE A.
.
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD WILL SOON BE
SIXTY.
WHO'LL.
BE TAKING DRIVER TRAINING.
AND DRIVER EDUCATION.
AND I'VE I'VE I'M SOLD AYE
GALWAY BACK TO AND WE HAD SOME
LEADERS.
FOR IT FOR DRIVING OUT OF THEY
HAVE NOW.
BUT BEATEN MISTER GLORIOUS
LOOKING AT ME LIKE I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO DO KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
IT TAUGHT YOU ADDRESS.
AND YOU WANT TO EXTENSIVE
TRAINING. ON THE RULES OF THE
ROAD.
AND WE REALLY DON'T HAVE THAT.
ACROSS THE BOARD NON HERE WHEN
IT COMES TO GUNS SAFETY.
AYE AYE.
I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS BECAUSE.
WE DO NEED TO HAVE BETTER A
BASELINE OF WHAT EVERY. ONE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA ON NEEDS TO OF.
TO DO COME UP TO.
WHETHER NOT THAT MUNICIPALITY
WANNA TAKE IT UP ANOTHER NOTCH
REVIEW MORE ACCEPTED LOCAL
MUNICIPALITY BUT I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT ACROSS STATE LINES WE
SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE.
A MINIMAL.
SET OF REQUIREMENTS INSTRUCTED
MENU ON THAT AND AND AND AND.
BECAUSE I'M IN OBSTINATE ES DE.
THAT WE GO AHEAD AND MOVE LISTEN
AND. THEN APPROVE THIS.
.
ARE MORE SOBERING.
THERE'S.
THIS NOTION OF WAITING.
FOR A PROBLEM.
.
TO HAPPEN I'M I DON'T PRESCRIBE
THAT.
I DON'T NEED TO SEE.
BODIES.
LINED UP IN THE HALLWAY.
BEFORE I DO SOMETHING TO PREVENT
THAT.
I DON'T THINK THIS LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO SEE.
FAMILIES TORN APART BECAUSE.
SOMEONE.
ON USES.
GUNS IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY
BECAUSE THEY GET THEY LACK OF
TRAINING.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED TO SEE
THAT CARNAGE BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD I THINK IT'S IT'S
BEST THAT WE HAVE A LEGISLATURE
THAT WE HAVE A GOVERNMENT.
DENTIST DE.
THE FORETHOUGHT TO THINK AHEAD
OF THIS.
AND TRY TO PREVENT IT.
AS OUR EVEN.
YOU SOME MISTER COLLEAGUES WORD.
HOPE I DON'T SEE ANY PROBLEM
WITH GOING AHEAD AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TRAINING.
.
SO I'M RECOMMENDED WE HAVE AYE
VOTE.
THE BIG PROBLEM OF CONSECUTIVE.
AB TWENTY ONE MAIENSCHEIN THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER ITEMS ARE AYE LACKEY.
CDVA CDVA I GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
BUILT ON CALL ANYBODY MORE THANK
YOU MISTER GLORIA.
AND ACTUALLY HAVE MISTER BONTA
A. B..
TWO ONE ZERO ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I GUESS YOU HAVE AND
YOU HAVE TWENTY ONE.
MY JUNE TWENTY SO YES.
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED FIRST MISTER
CHAIR.
AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WILL
STRENGTHEN THE VIOLENCE PEER
COUNSELING PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
PROGRAM.
IT WILL INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT PERIOD FROM TEN TO
TWENTY SIX WEEKS.
IT WILL ALSO INCREASE THE.
COMPENSATION AND REIMBURSEMENT
FROM FIFTEEN DOLLARS TO.
NO LESS THAN ONE HALF OF THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SET BY THE
BOARD FOR COUNSELING SERVICES
PROVIDED BY A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER WHICH IS ABOUT
FORTY ONE DOLLARS A FORTY
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS.
IT.
WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE POOL OF
ELIGIBLE RECIPIENTS TO INCLUDE
THOSE THEY MAY BE ON PROBATION
PAROLE POST LEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION OR MANDATORY
SUPERVISION IF THEY'RE VICTIMS
OF COURSE.
AND IN THE DISCRETION OF.
.
THE CABBIE CPM AND THEN FINALLY
THE BILL WE AUTHORIZES THE
VIOLENCE PER COUNTY PROVISIONS.
I WHICH IS SET TO EXPIRE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN.
SO I YOU KNOW THIS IS IT A PATH
GO BILL THAT BUILDS OFF A
SUCCESSFUL PILOT THEY MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO STRENGTHEN. AND
AT ABOUT PILOT AND.
WILL REALLY PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
TOM INFORMED CARE FOR VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIMES THAT THEY CAN
HEAL.
I HE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE AG
DEANGELO MAC INTERVENTION
SPECIALIST WITH WELL SPACE MIKE
MCCLOUD I'VE LEAVE AN ANALYST AT
GIFFORD'S LA CENTER. AND RUBEN
LAYOUT WITH COURAGE. ACREAGE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER.
YES.
WHENEVER.
THE ARE YOU READING AYE GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME'S ANGELA MAD
WITH WELL SPACE HELD SACRAMENTO
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
HOSPITAL BASED VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS OR ACE
VIP'S HAVE BEEN SHOWN
EFFECTIVELY TO BREAK THE CYCLE
OF VIOLENCE BY CONNECTING
CULTURALLY COMPETENT PEER
VIOLENCE. COUNSELORS
WITH CLIENTS DURING THE CRITICAL
TEACHABLE MOMENTS WHEN CLIENTS
ARE RECOVERING IN. THE HOSPITAL
FROM VIOLENT INJURIES.
PIERRE VIOLENCE COUNSELORS WORK
WITH CLIENTS FROM FOR MONTHS
AFTER DISCHARGE FROM THE
HOSPITAL TO ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING ROOT CAUSES OF
VIOLENCE.
STUDIES OF SHOWN THAT.
H. VIP'S INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
BASED PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL'S
WRAPAROUND PROJECT AND LOCAL
CALIFORNIA'S CAUGHT IN A
CROSSFIRE PROGRAM. TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH LARGE REDUCTIONS
IN BOTH A VIOLENT INJURIES BY
RECIDIVISM AND CRIME RECIDIVISM
FOR.
OUR CLIENTS GENERATING LARGE
COST SAVINGS
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS LIST
INTEND H. VIP'S ALTHOUGH OVERALL
DEMAND FOR THE SERVICES ARE MUCH
MUCH HIGHER. LACK OF FUNDING
SOURCES IT IS OFTEN CITED AS.
THE REASON FOR EACH GUY PIECE
NOT.
TO BE PRESIDENT.
IN MORE CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
BY LEE INJURED CRIME VICTIMS ON
PROBATION AND PAROLE.
FOR VIOLENT CRIME ARE AT
PARTICULARLY HIGH RATE RISK OF
BEING VIOLATED REINJURED
BECOMING INVOLVED IN RETALIATORY
VIOLENCE THEMSELVES PROVIDED.
A LIMITED NUMBER OF COUNSELING
SESSIONS AVAILABLE FOR HIGH RISK
HIGH NEED POPULATION SUBJECT TO
CAL BCB DISCRETION. IS A IS A
SMART AND TARGET USE OF VICTIM
COMPENSATION DOLLARS AND MAY
SAVE STATES DOLLARS IN THE LONG
RUN AND ALLOWED BY HIS
PREVENTION PROFESSIONALS TO.
HELP PREVENT PEOPLE ON PROBATION
AND PAROLE FROM VIOLATING THE
TERMS OF PROBATION AND PAROLE
AND RE ENTERING THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED IS A
TRAUMA INFORMED APPROACH THAT
PROVIDES A WHOLE PERSON CARE TO
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE IN WAYS THAT
DO NOT CARRY STIGMA SOMETIMES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRADITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
THE SECOND A VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAM SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NEXT GOOD MORNING ON.
ON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROBIN THAT I DO WANT TO GIVE A
DISCLAIMER ON THEIR OWN. PUBLIC
SPEAKING IS NOT MY FORTE ABOVE
ALL I'M REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AS ONE HERE OWN.
MOMENT. IN TWO THOUSAND TEN OWN
HOUSE A SURVIVOR OF A OF A
GUNSHOT ON.
WOUND AND.
AT THAT TIME ON.
OWN.
A LOT OF EMOTIONS COME UP AFTER
YOU LONG PASSWORD DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCE LIKE THAT. AND.
ON.
WORLD WOULD REALLY HELP ME IN
THROUGH THAT PROCESS WAS LONG.
HAVEN'T COMMUNITY MEMBERS ON BE
THERE TO SUPPORT OF ME AND
ACTUALLY EXPLAIN WHAT I'M GOING
THROUGH. LIKE OF THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL AFFECTS THE FEAR
THE PARANOIA THE ON. THE BEING
HAVEN'T WALKED THROUGH THAT
SAME.
SPOT WHERE THAT HAPPENED WHAT
HAPPENED OUTSIDE MY HOUSE.
HOME I HAVEN'T FLOWN.
SO.
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO CAME OUT AND
SUPPORTED ME AND PEOPLE WHO ARE.
LIKE YOU THE LIVE LIKE CURRIE'S
OWN THAT CAME OUT AND OFFER
MENTORSHIP TO ME. THAT THAT CAME
TO VISIT ME AT THE HOSPITAL.
THAT HOME BASICALLY ON.
EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT WAS HAPPENING
WHAT WHAT THIS ALONE ON
PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECTS AND HOME
OF THAT KIND OF TRAUMA HAD HIM
ON MY BODY.
AND BE ABLE TO OWN SO THE.
YEAH START THE HEALING JOURNEY
AND ON.
YES SO SO WERE.
WELL WHY WILL LOW'S ABLE TO COME
OUT WAS ON BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THOSE EMOTIONS INSTEAD OF HIDING
ON THE SET OF MASK IN THEM
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THROUGH. A LOT
OF ON DIFFERENT NEGATIVE ON
OUTLETS I WAS ABLE TO OWN.
SO I UNDERSTAND AND AND
BASICALLY MOVE ON WITH MY LIFE
AND RIGHT NOW I CURRENTLY WORK
AS A HOME. MENTOR FOR THE YOUNG
FOLKS THAT ARE DEALING WITH THE
SAME ISSUES THAT I DEAL WITH SO
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU WE DID EXTREMELY WELL
SIR.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MIKE MAKE
LIVELY I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT GIFFORD'S LA CENTER
AND I DIRECTOR URBAN GUN
VIOLENCE INITIATIVE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER SCHOOL
SHOOTING THIS MORNING THIS TIME
IN MARYLAND AND THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT I THINK IS ON EVERYONE'S
MIND IS WHAT CAN WE DO. AS A
COUNTRY WHAT CAN YOU DO AS
LEGISLATORS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO ADDRESS THIS EPIDEMIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR COUNTRY AND TO
OUR STATE'S CREDIT WE DO HAVE
SOME OF THE STRONGEST. GUN LAWS
IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT WHAT WE STILL NEED TO DO IS
IDENTIFY AND SCALE OUT EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES THAT REALLY GET
AT THE ROOT. OF GUN VIOLENCE IN
OUR STATE AND HOSPITAL BASED
BALLOTS INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE ONE OF THOSE SOLUTIONS THAT
REALLY DESERVE OUR SUPPORT. AYE
CALIFORNIA STILL HAS DESPITE ITS
GUN LAWS STILL HAS MORE THAN A
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
KILLED BY GUN RELATED HOMICIDE
EACH YEAR. AND OVER FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE SHOT NON
FATALLY IN THE STATE SO WE STILL
HAVE AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM WITH
GUN VIOLENCE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. THIS STRATEGY IS SO
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING INJURY
RECIDIVISM BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN SHOT AT A VERY HIGH
RISK OF BEING SHOT AGAIN AND OUR
HOSPITALS HAVE ESSENTIALLY
BECOME REVOLVING DOORS. WHERE
PEOPLE WITH A GUNSHOT INJURY
RECEIVE ACTS LIKE CARE AND
TREATMENT BUT ARE THEN RELEASED
BACK INTO THE SAME EXACT
SITUATION THAT GOT THEM THERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE?
AND SO HOSPITAL WE FOUND THAT
INVENTION PROGRAMS
REALLY USE THAT TEACHABLE MOMENT
WHERE SOMEONE HAS BEEN BADLY
INJURED AND THEY'RE READY TO
HEAR MESSAGE OF CHANGE THEY'RE
READY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
ROOT CAUSES.
THAT LED TO THE INJURY IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND SOME OF THE VERY
HEROIC. PEER VIOLENCE COUNSELORS
THAT ARE EMPLOYED BY EACH VIP'S
HAVE HELPED TO REDUCE YOUR
SENTIMENT RECIDIVISM RATES OF
INJURY AND CRIME IN CITIES LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO. AND. I IN THE IN
THE HANDFUL OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE ACROSS OUR STATE WE'VE SEEN
STUDIES THAT SHOW HOW EFFECTIVE
THESE PROGRAMS ARE. SO AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED IS THE COMMON SENSE
AND REALLY A MODEST PROPOSAL TO
HELP USE VICTIM COMPENSATION
DOLLARS TO REIMBURSE THEM THEIR
PEER VIOLENCE COUNSELORS. THAT
ARE PROVIDING THIS VERY CRITICAL
SERVICE WHERE THEY'RE CONNECTING
WITH FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN SHOT
WORKING WITH THEM AFTER THEY'VE
BEEN DISCHARGED FROM THE
HOSPITAL TO HELP IDENTIFY ROOT
CAUSES LIKE. LACK OF EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES.
GANG MEMBERSHIP WHATEVER IT IS
THAT MIGHT HAVE LED SOMEONE TO
BE SHOT IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
SO THIS IS SUCH AN EFFECTIVE
POLICY THERE ARE ONLY A HANDFUL
OF AIDS VIP'S IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO ADDRESS OUR GUN
VIOLENCE PROBLEM WE NEED MANY
MORE OF THESE PROGRAMS IN PLACE
AND AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED IS ONE
WAY TO HELP ENCOURAGE.
THESE PROGRAMS TO EXPAND AND
GROW BY PROVIDING MODEST
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE FOLKS THAT
ARE PROVIDING THE SERVICES ON
THE GROUND AND WE THINK IT
DIFFERENCE LAS AND OUR. THAT
EMBRACING THE STRATEGY AT THE
STATE LEVEL EYES AN IMPORTANT
STRATEGY FOR DEALING WITH THE
URBAN GOT ABOUT THAT REALLY
DRIVES THE MAJORITY OF SHOOTINGS
THAT WE SEE. IN OUR STATE SO WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OR ANY OF THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
AMANDA WILCOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
IN SUPPORT.
YOU THE LIVE FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
PAISLEY BOWMAN ACLU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
MATT SNYDER SACRAMENTO VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM A SPORT.
RIGHT AFTER MY NOVELLAS WITH
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR STARTED
JUSTICE IN OAKLAND WHERE CO
SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT.
JOSE REINA.
FROM CURRY IT'S COMMUNITIES YOU
NOT A POOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA ALSO
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS
REMOVE OUR BELL.
GONZALEZ SECOND.
YOU MAY.
EQUIPMENT CONCLUDE AT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES THIS
IS A A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
IMPROVES UPON A SUCCESSFUL PILOT
MAKES IT STRONGER AND HELPS
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED IT AYE
HE'LL. AYE AND REENTER OUR
COMMUNITY SUCCESSFULLY A
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU.
JEREC IMAGE AND AYE VOTE ME
COLDER RULE EIGHTY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
YOU THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
THERE YOU. CDVA AYE ON HIS
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO.
BILL PASSES.
THANK YOU.
BUT BEFORE YOU BEGIN THE NEXT
WEEK I WILL GO THROUGH SOME
HOUSE.
.
FONG OFF CALENDAR TODAY AND I'M
I APOLOGIZE FOR ANYBODY IT WAS
WAITING FOR ANY OF THESE.
.
A BABY NINETEEN ELEVEN LACKEY
NUMBER ONE WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
BABY NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT QUIRK
SILVA WITH PULL BODY OFF AFTER
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AND IN ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY FOURTEEN
EDUARDO. GARCIA WAS PULLED ALSO
PULLED BY THE OFFICE.
IN ADDITION.
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
OF ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE QUIRK.
PULLED ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR CERVANTES.
PULLED I MEET THAT PULLED UP ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY
SEVENTY EIGHT DAILY. ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB TWENTY EIGHTY SURVIVED
THIS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY THREE WEBER ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SIX BONTA.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY SIX JONES SAWYER.
AT NIGHT IN A SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN JONES
SAWYER.
I'M AYE NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY SEVEN BIGELOW.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SEVEN QUIRK.
I DON'T UNDER TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY NINE CHEN. ITEM
THE TWENTY TWO A. B. TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY ONE FLORA AND FINALLY.
I NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
FIVE BOTH SEVEN JONES SAWYER
AND.
THE MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR
CHAU MOVE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE GENDER AYE
LACKEY.
CDVA VIDEO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
PUT THAT IS THAT YOUR AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK EYES SANTIAGO.
SENATE KILLERS THAT COPPED IT.
SO GOING TO MISS
BONTA.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES PLEASED
FOR THAT AB NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN.
AND ONE I THINK.
A CHAIR AND STUFF FOR THE HELP
THAT YOU PROVIDED ON THIS
MEASURE AB NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN
WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE WHO FEAR
COMMITTING SUICIDE TO
VOLUNTARILY AND.
CONFIDENTIALLY ADD THEIR OWN
NAME TO A CALIFORNIA DO NOT SELL
LIST
TO PREVENT THEMSELVES FROM
PURCHASING.
A FIREARM SUICIDE HAS SURPASSED.
HOMICIDES AS THE MOST PREVALENT
CAUSE OF DEATH RESULTING FROM
THE MIS USE OF A FIREARM DESPITE
A TEN DAY. WAITING PERIOD A
STUDY FOUND THAT CAL THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE FIFTY SEVEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT.
SUICIDE IN THE FIRST WEEK AFTER
PURCHASING A FIREARM FIREARMS
ARE ALSO. AT THE MOST LETHAL AND
MOST COMMON METHOD OF SUICIDE
MORE PEOPLE WHO DIE BY SUICIDE
USE A FIREARM THAT ALL OTHER
METHODS COMBINED ABOUT EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT.
OF SUICIDE ATTEMPTS WITH A
FIREARM AND IN DEATH AS COMPARED
TO FIVE PERCENT ONLY FOR OTHER
OF METHODS OF SUICIDE ATTEMPTS
WE KNOW THAT. SUICIDE CAN BE AN
IMPULSIVE DECISION PEOPLE
USUALLY MAKE A DECISION TO KILL
THEMSELVES AN ATTEMPT TAKE THEIR
LIFE. IN LESS THAN A DAY.
NINETY PERCENT OF THOSE WHO
SURVIVE A SUICIDE ATTEMPT DO NOT
GO ON TO DIE BY SUICIDE HOWEVER
SUICIDE ATTEMPTS WITH A FIREARM.
REALLY AFFORD A SECOND CHANCE
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW PEOPLE.
AT RISK FOR SUICIDE HAVE THE
OPTION TO PREVENT THEMSELVES
FROM BUYING A FIREARM DURING A
TIME WHEN THEY FEAR. THEY CAN
HARM THEMSELVES SPECIFICALLY AB
NINETY TWENTY SEVEN. WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO DEVELOP AND LAUNCH A
SECURE INTERNET BASED PLATFORM
TO ENABLE A PERSON TO
VOLUNTARILY CONFIDENTIALLY AT
THEIR NAME. TO THE DO NOT SELL
LIST.
THAT WILL PREVENT THEM FOR
PURCHASING A FIREARM.
THEY CAN REMOVE THEIR NAME AT
ANY TIME UPON REQUEST AFTER
YEAR.
AND AND PRIOR TO YEAR THEY CAN
REMOVE THEIR NAME WITH THAT
SUPPORT OF DECLARATION FROM A
LICENSED PHYSICIAN OR
PSYCHOLOGIST OR PSYCHIATRIST
INDICATING THAT THE NOT.
A SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF HARM TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED MANY OF
THE STRONGEST.
A.
LAWS TO ADDRESS GUN VIOLENCE AND
BUT WE HAVEN'T YET. TAKEN ON
THIS UNIQUE ISSUE THIS UNIQUE
SPACE WHICH CAN REALLY SAVE A
LOT OF LIVES WHICH IT WILL HELP
RESTRICT INDIVIDUALS ABILITY
SELF RESPECT INDIVIDUALS ABILITY
TO PURCHASE. THEIR OWN FIREARM
WE'RE NOT ALONE IN THIS EFFORT
TO IMPLEMENT THIS POLICY
APPROACH FIVE OTHER STATES ARE
MOVING SIMILAR BILLS RIGHT NOW.
AND STATE OF WASHINGTON THERE'S
A BILL THAT SOMEONE TO OURS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AWAITING THE
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE.
AND AS THIS BILL MOVES ALONG A
PLAN TO. DO ADDITIONAL WORK IF.
BAH I'M ABLE TO MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON TO THE NEXT STEP.
I REGARDING IDENTITY
VERIFICATION.
INTO THE ALSO INCLUDE A PENALTY
FOR FALSELY SIGNING SOMEONE ELSE
UP FOR INCLUSION ON THE LIST
ANOTHER THAT'S BEEN RAISED AS AN
ISSUE WE WANT TO WORK ON THAT
ISSUE. AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A ROBUST MEASURES TO
PREVENT SUCH A THING FROM
HAPPENING.
WITH AB NAKED TWENTY SEVEN WE
CAN GIVE INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF
SUICIDE THE TOOLS TO BE
PROACTIVE AND SAVE THEIR OWN
LIVES.
AND ARE WE WE KNOW THE STUDIES
THAT SHOW THAT A UP TO FORTY
PERCENT OF INDIVIDUALSWITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WOULD SIGN
UP FOR SUCH A LIST IF IT WERE
OFFERED TO THEM. SO WE THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
USED ARAB IT IF IT WERE ABLE TO
ENACTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
IF IT SAVES ONE LIFE
I THINK IT'S MORE THAN WORTH IT
SO I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME TWO WITNESSES I
HAVE ANY ERRORS PROFESSOR AT
YALE LAW SCHOOL WHO HELPED
DEVELOP THIS PROPOSAL IN THIS
CONCEPT. ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT IS
AMANDA WILCOX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT.
GUN VIOLENCE.
GOOD MORNING THAT MY NAME IS IAN
HEIRESS AYE I'M THE WILLIAM
TOWNS AND PROFESSOR AT YALE LAW
SCHOOL. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN AB NINETEEN TO TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA
COULD TO CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
WAY ON SENSIBLE. GUN REGULATION.
ALTHOUGH MASS
SHOOTINGS GRAB THE HEADLINES GUN
SUICIDE CLAIMS MANY MANY MORE
LIVES.
THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTER KILLED
FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE GUN SUICIDE
KILLS THE SAME NUMBER OF PEOPLE
EVERY DAY.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
ALLOW PEOPLE WHO FEAR SUICIDE
PUT DISTANCE BETWEEN THEMSELVES
AND FIREARMS.
THE BILL IN EFFECT ALLOWS PEOPLE
TO OPT INTO A LONGER WAITING
PERIOD.
THE CURRENT WAITING PERIOD IS
NOT ENOUGH TO PREVENT MANY
SUICIDES.
JOE'S OF BREMEN WAITED THE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED DELAY
PERIOD FOR DELIVERY OF A A NEW
HANDGUN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN THE THREE DAYS LATER
THAT I SHOT HIMSELF BUT I AS
REPORTED IN THE LA TIMES BREMEN
WAS SITTING IN THE BEDROOM OF
HIS. OAKLAND HOME WITH HIS WIFE
MICHELLE WHO'S BLIND THE COUPLE
WERE. MAKINGOUT A GROCERY
SHOPPING LIST IN BREMEN WHO HAD
JUST TAKEN A SHOWER GOT UP AND
WENT TO THE BATHROOM. MICHELLE
BREMEN HEARD WHAT SHE THOUGHT
WAS THE WAS A CAR BACKFIRE THEN
SHE HEARD WHAT SATELLITE WATER
SPLASHING AGAINST THE SHOWER
CURTAIN AND WONDERED WHY. BREMEN
WITH WAS BATHING AGAIN. AND THEN
I THOUGHT I SMELLED GUNPOWDER
SHE SAID I SCREAM FOR HIM AND I
RAN INTO THE BATHROOM. BRAIN WAS
SLUMPED OVER THE BATHTUB IS
BLOOD FROM HIS HEAD SPRAYED
AGAINST THE SHOWER CURTAIN.
JOSEPH BREMEN IS NOT ALONE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA KILL THEMSELVES EACH
YEAR.
.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN
PROVIDES MUCH MORE PROTECTION.
THEN.
A WAITING PERIOD DURING THE
FIRST YEAR AFTER SIGNING UP A
PERSON CAN PURCHASE A GUN ONLY
IF THEY SUBMIT A DECLARATION
FROM A PHYSICIAN OR
PSYCHOLOGIST.
ATTESTING THAT THE PARTICIPANT
IS NOT PRESENT A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK OF HARM. TO SELF OR OTHERS
WITH A FIREARM. THERE GOOD
REASON TO THINK THIS ADDED LAYER
PROTECTION WILL PREVENT MANY
SUICIDES.
THE GREAT VIRTUE OF THIS BILL IS
THAT IT'S COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY
NO ONE IS AFFECTED TOO DOESN'T
WANT TO BE.
BUT A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM IS IT IS
EFFECTIVE OF COURSE ONLY IF
PEOPLE VOLUNTEER WHAT'S WHAT IF
CALIFORNIA PASSES THE BILL BUT
NO ONE SIGNS UP.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN AND
I I KNOW THIS FOR PERSONAL AS
WELL AS EMPIRICAL REASONS.
MY COAUTHOR FRED VARS AND I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN TWO
DIFFERENT STUDIES
SHOWING THAT MORE THAN FORTY
PERCENT OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH MENTAL ILLNESSES.
WOULD BE WILLING TO WAIVE THEIR
RIGHTS TO PURCHASE GUNS.
ONE STUDY OF PEOPLE SEEKING
PSYCHIATRIC CARE AT A MAJOR
MEDICAL CENTER FOUND THAT FORTY
SIX PERCENT WOULD RESTRICT THEIR
FUTURE GUN PURCHASES IN THIS
WAY.
A MORE RECENT STUDY OF INTERNET
USERS FOUND THAT ABOUT A THIRD
OF THE GENERAL POPULATION AND
FORTY THREE PERCENT OF THOSE WHO
HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY DIAGNOSED.
WITH AMENTAL DISORDER WOULD BE
WILLING TO WAIVE THE RIGHT TO
PURCHASE OR POSSESS GUNS.
THE DEMAND FOR THIS KIND OF
VOLUNTARY WAIVER ISN'T ABSTRACT
MY CO AUTHOR ON THIS STUDY. FRED
VARS HAS BIPOLAR DISORDER AND
HAS AT TIMES IN THE PAST BEEN
SUICIDAL FRED CAME UP WITH THIS
IDEA OF A WAIVER REGISTRY.
BECAUSE HE REALIZED THAT HE IT
COULD HELP HIM SAVE HIS OWN
LIFE.
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF PEOPLE WITH
BIPOLAR DISORDER DIED BY SUICIDE
IF FRED HAD HAD EASY ACCESS TO A
GUN AT CERTAIN POINTS IN HIS
LIFE HE'D ALREADY BE ONE OF
THEM.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER BEEN
SEVERELY DEPRESSED CAN'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT'S LIKE YOU
LOSE JOY YOU LOSE HOPE.
AND YOU LOSE THE ABILITY TO
MAKE RATIONAL DECISIONS.
HOWEVER LIKE ALMOST ALL PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
FRED HAS PERIODS OF CLARITY
DURING THESE THESE PERIODS HE
WANTS TO PROTECT HIMSELF AGAINST
FUTURE DARK DAYS.
TWO MONTHS AGO THE PARKLAND
MASSACRE A BILL FOR TWO MONTHS
BEFORE THE PARKLAND MASSACRE.
SHOOTER HIMSELF NICOLAS CREWS
CALLED NINE ONE ONE AND TOLD THE
DISPATCHER THAT HE QUOTE KIND OF
GOT MAD AND STARTED PUNCHING
WALLS.
CRUISES CALL TO NINE ONE ONE WAS
A LITERAL CRY FOR HELP IF THE
DISPATCHER HAD ALERTED HIM TO AN
OPTION.
TO TEMPORARILY WAIVE HIS RIGHT
TO PURCHASE AND POSSESS FIREARMS
KEY LIKE HUNDREDS OF OTHER
PEOPLE IN OUR STUDIES MIGHT HAVE
VOLUNTARILY DISARMED.
THERE'S BEEN ESTIMATED THAT
THERE COULD YOU WRAP IT UP
BEYOND USING UP ALL THE FIVE
MINUTES AND I'M SORRY IN THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN I KNOW THEY WANT
TO SPEAK SORRY.
SO.
THAT THE COST OF.
THE ECONOMIC COSTS OF SUICIDE
ARE NOTHING COMPARED TO THE
PERSONAL AND EMOTIONAL COST I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO PASS A BE
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU.
I'LL I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF AGAIN
AMANDA WILCOX HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE.
THIS BILL SUPPORTS ARE CALLED
OUR CORE MISSION OF WHICH IS TO
REDUCE FIREARM INJURY AND DEATH
IN OUR NATION AS WELL AS IN OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SIXTY TWO PERCENT OF FIREARM
DEATHS NATIONALLY OR SUICIDE BY
FIREARMS. AND MORE THAN HALF OF
THE GUN DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA A
BY SUICIDE AND SADLY THAT NUMBER
IS GROWING PERHAPS BECAUSE GUN
OWNERSHIP. AYE IS INCREASING SO
CLEARLY TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE
IN OUR STATE WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM OF SUICIDE BY FIRE.
MANY OF OUR LOST MANY OF WHICH
I'VE WORKED ON AND YOU ALL HAVE
SUPPORTED. A DEAL WITH THAT.
OUR GOAL TO KEEP.
FIRE ARMS OUT THE HANDS OF
CRIMINALS AND DANGEROUS HANDS
BUT CLEARLY WE NEED TO TRUST THE
PROBLEM A SUICIDE BY FIREARM AND
WE NEED EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX TO DO THAT AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE TOOLS.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF OUR TWENTY
CALIFORNIA BRADY CHAPTERS OUR.
PEG MCCRAW MISS FROM LONG BEACH
CHAPTER AND SHE VERY MUCH WANTED
ME TO SHARE HER EXPERIENCE WHICH
IS THAT HER DAUGHTER ARE EXCUSE
ME HER SISTER SUFFERS FROM
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
HER SISTER IS A KIND GENTLE SOUL
BUT WHEN CHOOSING CRISIS SHE
DOES THINGS THAT SHE WOULD NOT
NORMALLY DO SHE'S NOT HERSELF.
AND HER SISTER WOULD BE
HORRIFIED IF SHE IN ANYWAY
INJURED ANOTHER PERSON ARE
OBVIOUSLY HERSELF A WHILE SHE'S
IN HER CRISIS STATE. IN THE BILL
OF THE TO SELF REFER TO A LESS.
I DO NOT SELL LISTS WOULD NOT
ONLY PUT HER SISTERS MINDED EAST
BUT ALSO THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
THE MY OWN PERSONAL STORIES I'M
FROM A RURAL COUNTIES YOU KNOW
NEVADA COUNTY ARE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROBLEM IS SUICIDE BY
FIREARM. ON MY DAUGHTER AS YOU
KNOW WAS KILLED IN THE RAMPAGE
SHOOTING BY AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS I ACTUALLY
BELIEVE HE IS TRYING TO DO
SUICIDE BY COP.
OR MAYBE IN THE END TO SHOOT
HIMSELF EATING GET THAT FAR BUT
HE KILLED THREE OTHERS.
SINCE THAT TIME I'VE BEEN ON
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION TASKFORCE
IN NEVADA COUNTY AND EVERYONE
HAS EMBRACE ALL STAKEHOLDERS THE
CONCEPT THAT MEANS MATTER HOW HE
TRIED TO KILL YOURSELF. MAKES A
BIG DIFFERENCE IN WEATHER THAT
SUICIDE IS COMPLETED AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOMEONE TRY
SOMETHING OTHER THAN A FIREARM.
THAT SUICIDE MAY NOT BE
COMPLETE IN THAT PERSON STILL
ALIVE. ON AND THAT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT PEOPLE
WHO ATTEMPT SUICIDE.
BUT DO NOT SUCCEED AND THEREFORE
LIVE DO NAP LATER DIE BY SUICIDE
BECAUSE WE OFTEN HEAR THEY DON'T
HAVE A FIREARM THAT JUST TRY
SOMETHING ELSE.
APPOINTMENTS.
BY SUPERVISOR AND BOTH ON THAT
TASK FORCE I MENTIONED THE
MENTAL HEALTH FOR WERE VERY
FOCUSED ON. EMPOWERING CLIENTS
OUGHT TO MAKE.
GOOD DECISIONS REGARDING THEIR
OWN SELF CARE TO DEVELOP THEIR
OWN SAFETY PLANS AND TO.
USED TO EMPOWER THEM TO USE
THEIR OWN ACTIONS ARE TO MAKE
THEIR LIVES BETTER AND SAFER IN
THIS IS VERY CONSISTENT WITH
THAT PHILOSOPHY. THAT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN NEVADA COUNTY
HAVE.
FINALLY IF YOU'LL BEAR WITH ME
FOR JUST A MOMENT I GET VERY
UPSET WHEN I HEAR OVER AND OVER
HALF THE SHOOTINGS AND I SEE IN
THE AGAIN AND ANNOUNCES. THAT
WERE SPOKE FOCUSED ON GUNS
INSTEAD OF THE UNDERLINING
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT AN EITHER OR OBVIOUSLY
IT'S BOTH.
RIGHT.
MY HUSBAND I WORKED VERY HARD TO
GET THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT PASSED GAVE A LOT PERSONAL
MONEY TO IT TO GET MORE
RESOURCES FOR MENTAL HEALTH CARE
IN CALIFORNIA. LAURA'S LAW WAS
NAMED AFTER MY DAUGHTER AND
THAT'S TO GET THOSE WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS WITH NO INSIGHT.
I INTO THE ILLNESS INTO
TREATMENT THROUGH COURT ORDER I
MENTIONED I'VE BEEN ON THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION TASK FORCE
AMONG THE MENTAL HEALTH BOARD
WHERE WE DETERMINE OUR
PRIORITIES. UNDERSTANDING AND
WELTS NEEDING CAO OF IN NEVADA
COUNTY AND HOLDING UP OUR OUR
PROVIDERS IN OUR COUNTY
ACCOUNTABLE.
OR WORKSHEET HUTTON HEADS AND
OBVIOUSLY WE DO THAT NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT ASPECT I DON'T
THINK ANYONE AGREES BUT WHY WE
DEAL WITH THOSE ISSUES WHICH A
VERY HARD IN COMPLICATED TERMS
OF. MENTAL HEALTH CARE LESS IT'S
STILL ONLY STOP THE BLEEDING BY
REMOVING ACCESS TO FIREARMS BY
THOSE WHO ARE AT RISK OF DANGER
TO SELF OR OTHERS.
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE A FAIRLY COME BEHALF OF
DIFFERENT LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE CAN SUPPORT.
OKAY VERY WELL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. OF CHIU.
ADDRESS THE WORKABILITY ISSUES
TO ACCOMPLISH THE WORTHY GOALS
THAT THAT THE BILL.
AIMS FOR ON WITHOUT ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IN THE
FOR TO CONTINUE THAT DISCUSSION
THANK YOU.
OKAY YES.
M. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THAT
GOES CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CURRICULA ON BEHALF OF
THE FIREARMS POLICY COALITION IN
OPPOSITION.
WE ARE YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT THE THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO DO IN OUR CONCERNS ARE
PRIMARILY REGARDS TO INDIVIDUALS
BEING ADDED TO THE LIST TO
AREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE
LIST. A ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH ANY INTERNET BASED
GOVERNMENT DATABASE.
THERE THERE ARE CONCERNS OF
IDENTITY THEFT AND WE'RE IN AN
AGE WHERE IDENTITY THEFT IS A
HUGE ISSUE. A OUR OUR CONCERN IS
THAT IN INDIVIDUALS SOMEONE MAY
OBTAIN SOMEONE'S INFORMATION AND
REGISTER THEM ON THE THIS ON
THIS WEBSITE. AND WE KNOW THAT
THIS HAPPENS ALREADY BECAUSE
THERE ARE ALREADY EVIDENCE OF
PEOPLE WHO GET ALL WHO WHO
REGISTER TO VOTE ONLINE THAT ARE
EXPLICITLY REGISTER TO VOTE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
TAX ID'S THAT ARE SUPPOSE TO BE
ABLE TO GET TAX ID'S ARE PEOPLE
APPLYING FOR TAX REFUNDS THERE
AREN'T SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE GET
TAX REFUNDS.
A OUR CONCERN IS THAT.
EYES IS FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT
ONCE AGAIN GETTING ON THIS LIST
AND THEY WANT IT GIVE PEACE
PEOPLE MAY BE ADDED TO THIS LIST
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ON THIS
LIST. OF OREGON IS OFFERED A
MEASURES WERE ACTUALLY YOU GO
INTO THE COUNTY CLERK'S OFFICE
AND YOU HAVE YOUR NAME ADDED TO
THE LIST AND. AND THEN YOU'D GO
IN THE COUNTY CLERK'S OFFICE AND
HAVE YOUR NAME REMOVED UP FROM
THE LIST A DID THAT'S A. WE
BELIEVE THAT IS A MUCH MORE AYE
TENABLE INSUPPORTABLE POSITION.
DANNY IS THAT IS HAVING ONE
ONCE AGAIN INTERNET BASED
WEBSITE THE OTHER CONCERN THAT
WE HAVE IS BY REPORTING THIS
INFORMATION TEN NECKS.
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL BASED
SYSTEM OUT WHILE THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY MAY SAY THAT YOU
HAVE NOT CREATE YOU HAVE NOT
COMMITTED A CRIME IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHAT YOU MAY BE
DOING BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE ADDED
TO THE NEXT AT A BASE AND THEN
IF YOU ATTEMPT A PURCHASE A
FIREARM? YOU STILL REUS IS AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT AND READ IT YOU
STILL MAY HAVE COMMITTED A
FEDERAL CRIME BY BEING
PROHIBITED ATTEMPTING TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM ONCE AGAIN
NOTHING IN THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. OF THE
OTHER CONCERN THAT WE HAVE IS IS
ONCE AGAIN WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY IT NEEDS TO BE REPORTED
WHITE NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED IN
NEXT ANYWAY UNLESS IS A CONCERN
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL. WHO'S
THINKING ABOUT COMMITTING
SUICIDE IS GOING TO DRIVE ACROSS
STATE LINES IN ORDER TO BE IN
ORDER TO PURCHASE FIREMAN OF THE
STATE WHICH BY THE WAY HAPPENS
TO BE A CRIME.
SO.
ANYWAY THE FOR THESE REASONS
ONCE AGAIN WE WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
OF THE ISSUE THAT OF THE AUTHOR
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS A WE HAVE
THESE THESE PRIMARY CONCERNS. I
ENDO IS UNFORTUNATE THAT
UNFORTUNATE WERE GONNA HAVE TO
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE AS IT'S
CURRENTLY DRAFTED.
THANK YOU.
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
RECORD DAN READ.
AT THIS TIME WERE WERE IN
OPPOSITION AYE ECHOED THE
CONCERNS OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
TO LOSE HIS HAS.
.
STATED HERE AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS. DONE HAS
BROUGHT SOME AMENDMENTS AND IS
WILLING TO WORK TO ADDRESS A
PRIMARILY THAT THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS IN THE VERIFICATION OF
WHO IS ACTUALLY GOING INTO THIS
DATABASE.
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE FURTHER
PROTECTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WITH THE SAME OR SIMILAR
NAMES OR DATE OF BIRTH ETCETERA.
I'M ARE NOT INADVERTENTLY
GETTING INTO THE SYSTEM.
AND THEN AS WELL AS MAKING SURE
THAT.
AS MR LUCE MENTIONED WITH THE
NEXT ISSUE.
I KNOW THERE IS LANGUAGE IN
THERE THAT TALKS ABOUT REGULARLY
UPDATING NEXT BUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN THE EVENT THAT SOMEONE'S
INADVERTENTLY PUT IN THERE THAT
THEY ARE REMOVED SO THEY DON'T.
A.
THEY'RE NOT AT RISK OF
COMMITTING A FEDERAL CRIME
EXETER SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IN
SAMPRAS REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY WE'VE TAKEN
A POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT I
WANT TO INFORM THE COMMITTEE.
THAT THE NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION LAST YEAR
LAUNCHED ONE OF THE LARGEST
NATIONWIDE AYE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS. WHERE THEY
ARE TALKING TO?
GUN RANGES GUN STORES.
MANUFACTURERS ALL PEOPLE IN THE
IN THE FIREARMS INDUSTRY IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM IDENTIFY. A
PEOPLE WHO ARE POTENTIAL FOR
SUICIDE AND TO.
HELP GET THEM SOME HELP SO I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT AS OF
LAST YEAR. THE FIREARMS INDUSTRY
IN THE FARMS ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
BEEN VERY ACTIVELY INVOLVED WITH
SOME OF THE MAJOR ANTI SUICIDE
GROUPS IN THE COUNTRY IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
WHERE WE CAN HELP HIM AT THAT
GUN RANGES IN THE GUN STORES AND
I THINK THAT'S A BIG HELP? I I
HOPE THAT IS HELPFUL TO THE TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE
AUTHOR TO TO SEE THAT WE ARE
NOT.
FOR SUICIDE WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
AGAINST.
SO.
SOME WOMEN QUIRK I'VE SEEN FIND
THAT FUNNY.
THANK MOVE THE BILL.
.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THREE JAMS KILEY.
I CITING THIS IS.
I REALLY.
CONSTRUCTIVE PROPOSAL AND I'M
GLAD BUT AFFORD AN AYE AYE. AYE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE OF
SUICIDE YES GUN RELATED SUICIDES
WHICH PROBABLY DOES NOT GET
ENOUGH ATTENTION.
AFTER POLICYMAKERS PERHAPS
BECAUSE TO TAKE A PHRASE FROM
THE LAST PRESENTER YOU DON'T SEE
AS MUCH ON THE NIGHTLY NEWS.
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO OUT TO WORK WITH
THAT THE OPPOSITION AROUND THESE
ISSUES OF A POTENTIAL FRAUD I AM
I WOULD BE OKAY MISTER.
A CHAIR TO ASK MR UP MISTER
AYERS LE TO COME BACK AS A
COUPLE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I KNOW
THIS IS.
THE PROFESSOR AS HEIRS.
SINCE THIS IS SORT OF ROOTED IN
THE STYLE WATER YOU ARTICLE HE
HAS HERE.
WHICH IS WHICH IS AN
INTERESTING ARTICLE AND I REALLY
APPLAUD THE SORT OF FRESH AND
ORIGINAL.
IDEA I'D I NOTICED THAT IN
YEARS MODEL A PROPOSAL WHAT'S A
TWENTY ONE DAY.
YOU CALL YOUR FOR THIS IS THE
DURABILITY OF YOUR WAIVER AND
DIE UNDER YOUR PROPOSAL.
YOU CAN WAVE AT ANY TIME.
AND THEN JUST TWENTY ONE DAYS
LATER YOU. SORT OF.
RESUME YOUR.
ORDINARY SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS WHEREAS WITH THIS IT'S A
YEARLONG.
PROCESS UNLESS YOU GET THAT
SORT OF POSITION ARE
PSYCHIATRISTS KNOW WHICH I'M NOT
SURE HOW. OFTEN THAT WOULD BE
UTILIZED SO WHAT DO YOU WHY DID
YOU MAKE THE CHOICE TO MAKE IT A
TWENTY ONE DAY.
PERIOD IN YOU KNOW WHILE YOU
HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH THE WAY
THIS IS FORMED. WELL V. THE
QUESTION OF HOW DURABLE.
THE WAIVER.
THAT I SHOULD BE IS.
.
CAN DEPEND ON WHAT THE
BACKGROUND RULES OF PARTICULAR
STATES AND SO SAFE THAT DON'T
HAVE A WAITING PERIOD AT ALL TO
GO. THERE THERE'S A LOT OF
EVIDENCE THAT.
.
THAT GUN SUICIDE IS OFTEN
IMPULSIVE AND IF YOU CAN GET
PEOPLE THROUGH THAT PERIOD OF
IMPULSE.
YOU CAN SAVE A LOT OF LIVES AND
THAT PERIOD OF IMPULSIVE VARIES
IN LENGTH AND.
AND GETTING THEM.
IF IF THERE'S A STATE THAT HAS
NO WAITING PERIOD.
SEVEN DAYS WOULD SAVE SOME
LIVES AND.
THREE WEEKS WOULD SAVE SOME
MORE LIVES AND A YEAR WOULD SAVE
SOME MORE LIVE AND THERE IS A.
AND SO ONE ONE VERY PRACTICAL
QUESTION IS JUST.
TAKING IN A PARTICULAR STATE
WHERE IDEAS AND THINKING ABOUT.
WHAT KIND OF AN EXTRA OPTIONS
YOU'RE GOING TO GET INDIVIDUALS
TO LENGTHEN THE WAITING PERIOD
FROM WHAT IT CURRENTLY IS THAT'S
A MANDATORY MATTER?
RIGHT SO IT SEEMS LIKE IF YOUR
PROPOSAL IS AS YOU AYE IN YOUR
MODEL OR ADOPT IN CALIFORNIA. IT
ACTUALLY WOULDN'T DO ALL THAT
MUCH BECAUSE MOST OF THE
BENEFITS RT CAPTURED UNDER
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LAW BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE TEN DAY WAITING
HEARING YOU SAY HERE IN THE
ARTICLE. A SUBSTANTIAL
PERCENTAGE KINDLY TO SET UP A
CENTRAL TO THE REGISTRANTS TO
RESCIND THE WAIVER BECAUSE THEY
WISH TO KILL THEMSELVES
ACCORDINGLY ARE NOT LIKELY TO
SEE IN THIS DESIRE OVER ENFORCED
WAITING PERIOD. AND SO I.
YOU KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
ALREADY REALIZING A LOT OF WHAT
YOU'RE PROPOSAL WOULD DO UNDER
EXISTING LAW SO WHAT DO YOU
ENVISION IS KIND OF THE THE
MARGINAL BENEFIT. OF OF THIS
BILL DOES PEOPLE THAT WOULD HAVE
SUSTAINED IMPULSES BEYOND. A
THREE WEEK PERIOD AND.
AND THE THE PROPORTION THAT
WOULD BE CAPTURED THAT YOU WOULD
SAVE IN JET WITH JUST A THREE
WEEK PERIOD VERSUS A YEAR
PERIOD.
THERE'S NOT STE
GREAT SOCIAL SCIENCE TO
DETERMINE OLD YOU'RE GOING TO
SAVE. EXPERTS SENT IN LINE AND
AND.
AND THAT'S WHAT WHY PERCENT IN
THE NEXT BUT THAT'S THE THE
SENSES YES.
THAT EVEN THAT TO GO FROM NO
WAITING PERIOD TOOL WEEK.
HAS BEEN ESTIMATED.
FAIRLY ACCURATELY TO SAVE LIVES
THERE'S JUST ISN'T AS MUCH
SOCIAL SCIENCE ON THE MOVE FROM
THREE WEEKS TO A YEAR RIGHT.
YEAH SO THAT'S WHERE I'M KIND OF
STRUGGLING WITH THIS IS THAT I
YOU KNOW THIS IMAGE OF YOU
WHAT'S THE SIDE TYING HIS HANDS
TO THE MAST THAT THE IDEA HERE
IS THAT YOUR.
RATIONAL SELF AT THIS MOMENT IN
TIME WILL.
PURPOSELY RESTRAIN YOUR FUTURE
SELF BUT WHEN YOU ALREADY HAVE A
WAITING PERIOD YOU'RE ACTUALLY
DEALING WITH TO FUTURE SELVES
RIGHT FUTURE SELF WOULD BY THE
GUN. IN THE FUTURE SELF THAT TEN
DAYS LATER WOULD THEN TAKE
ACTION THAT'S HARMFUL THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS WELL THAT THIS MIGHT
HELP YOU THE BILL ALSO HAS THIS
OPTION WHEN YOU REGISTER TO.
LEAVE UP TO FIVE EMAILS AND THIS
GOES.
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
A VERY PRACTICAL THING THAT THEY
CAN DO.
TO HELP HELP PEOPLE NOT JUST
REGISTER BUT TO LEAVE.
THEIR EMAIL ADDRESSES AND THAT
GIVES A LOVED ONES OR MET.
OR.
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS THEN A
THREE WEEK PERIOD.
TO.
CONTACT THIS PERSON. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR.
TRYING TO RESCIND OR TRYING TO
REGAIN THE RIGHT FOR.
REASONABLE PERIOD BECAUSE AFTER
YEAR YOU CAN'T RESCIND BUT.
THREE WEEKS FOR THAT TO BECOME
EFFECTIVE IF AFTER YOUR LONG
CAREER THAT'S RIGHT AND AND THAT
WOULD BE THREE WEEKS WORK ANY
EMAIL RECIPIENT COULD CHECK IN
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
NONE OF THE WAITING PERIODS
HAVE THIS EMAIL CHECK IN PERIOD
OF THREE WEEKS WHICH COULD.
THOUGHT YEAH DAVE LIVES
THAT MISTER BONTA GERMANY SINCE
THE COST OF SETTING UP THIS
WHOLE THING I MEAN I'VE SEEN SIR
REALLY MINOR TECHNOLOGIES THAT I
COULD.
ACCESS ON MY PHONE SUDDENLY
BECOME MILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS
FOR THE STATE AND THIS SEEMS
LIKE A PRETTY. MASSIVE SYSTEM
YOU HAVE ANY SENSE OF WHAT IT'S
GOING TO COST.
WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA TAKE KEEP
COSTS AS LOW AS POSSIBLE WE
THINK THIS IS OF THIS IS A
SEPARATE LIST FROM.
THE APPS LESS THAN AND SOME OF
THE OTHER LESS FIFTY ONE FIFTY
LISTED IT'S IT BUT TO DO NOT
SALAS THE PISSED OFF ON
VOLUNTARILY YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY GOVERNMENT HAS
STRUGGLED IN THE PAST WITH THE
AM SOME OF OUR DATABASES AND AND
AND TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS BUT WORKING WITH DOJ
NOW TO KEEP COSTS A MINIMAL.
DON'T EXPECT THIS TO HAVE A.
HIGH COST LIKE I CAN GIVE YOU
WHAT IT IS WE HAVE HAD
APPROPRIATIONS ANNOUNCES.
ALRIGHT SO THAT'S WHERE I KIND
AND I YOU KNOW THE THE.
WITNESS FROM THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
AYE I HEAR HER POINT THE YOU
DON'T WANT TO.
MAKE IT'S EITHER OR.
BY I ON THE OTHER HAND WHEN
WE'RE DEALING WITH I THINK
PRETTY SPECULATIVE BENEFITS HERE
GIVEN THE EXISTING WAITING
PERIOD IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
FACT THIS IS A YEAR LONG.
WEAVER PUREED AS OPPOSED TO THE
WASHINGTON BILLION REFERENCE
WHICH I THINK WAS ONE WEEK.
.
YOU DO NEED TO CONSIDER A CABLE
TO SPEND FIVE MILLION OR TEN
MILLION ON THIS.
IS THAT IT IS THIS GOING TO
SAVE MORE LIVES THAN SAVE HIRING
MORE COUNSELORS AT THAT HIGH
SCHOOLS WHO COULD ADDRESS
UNDERLYING.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SO THAT BE
PART OF MY CONCERN WITH THIS I
THINK. AND I I DO HAVE TO
MENTION A APART THIS ARTICLE
THAT I FOUND.
.
A LITTLE TROUBLING AND IS THIS
IDEA THAT.
THIS COULD SOMEHOW.
.
STILL TAPE SOCIAL RELATIONSHIPS
IN SOME WAY AND THERE'S THIS I
THOUGHT THAT YOU KNOW FRIEND AND
FAMILY DEMANDS TO KIND OF
REGISTER WITH THE SYSTEM MAY BE
A. COME A PREREQUISITE FOR
HIDING PLAYDATES AT SOMEONE'S
HOUSE OR OR FOR FAMILY VISITS IS
THAT HOW. YOU ENVISION THIS
PLAYING ITSELF OUT.
MISTER BONTA THAT I MEAN IT
SEEMS LIKE PARENTS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
GUNS THEY CANNOT CONVERSATIONS
AND SAY HOW ARE THEY STORED BUT
IN ARE WE GONNA HAVE A WORLD
HERE WHERE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
SAYING I'M NOT GONNA LET MY KID
GO PLAY YOUR HOUSE UNLESS YOU
REGISTER. WITH THE GOVERNMENT
AND THEN BY THE WAY YOU KNOW ME
HAVE THE GOVERNOR YOU MOMMY IF
YOU TRIED ON REGISTER.
I. KNOW THAT THAT IS NOT MY
VISION OF OF WHAT THIS BILL WILL
DO HOW IT WILL WORK MY VISION OF
HOW WHAT THIS BILL DO HOW WHAT
WILL WORK IS WHEN. THOSE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE THAT IN
A MOMENT OF CLARITY AND THEY
KNOW THAT THEY CAN BE DANGER TO
THEMSELVES THEY'LL TAKE RATIONAL
STEPS.
I TO KEEP HIMSELF SAFE AND
VOLUNTARY AND IT'S CONFIDENTIAL
NO ONE'S OPPOSING ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON ANYONE IT'S
SOMEONE DOING IT TO THEMSELVES
TO KEEP HIMSELF WELL AND SAFE.
THAT'S MY VISION OF THIS BILL
AND.
.
THAT'S ALL MY VISION OF THIS
BILL IS ALRIGHT THANK YOU CITING
OP STANFORD TODAY I THINK YOU'VE
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB
ADDRESSING CONCERNS FOR US ARE
THOSE ARE MINE AND I HOPE WE
CAN.
WORK TOGETHER ON IT ON FOR.
THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY YOU MAY. CONCLUDE.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT DISCUSSION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES AND.
ALL THE WITNESSES WHO TESTIFIED
I APPEAL TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS.
I THAT WE DISCUSSED PERSON
SPECIFICALLY AROUND
IDENTIFICATION AUTHENTICATION.
ON MAKING SURE THAT ONLY THOSE
WHO WISH TO BE ON THE LIST ARE
ON THE LIST AND THAT FRAUD IS IS
IS ROOTED OUT. AND WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT THE INTERSECTION OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND GUN VIOLENCE AND
THAT'S PRECISELY THE
INTERSECTION THAT THIS BILL OF
FOCUSES ON AND I THINK WE CAN
MAKE SOME PROGRESS WITH THIS
BILL IT'S AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH
WHICH I THINK HAS A LOT OF
PROMISE THAT COULD SAVE LIVES.
ESPECIALLY AFTER I VOTE THANK
YOU.
AND THANK YOU AND I AM GLAD THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK.
WITH THE ARM ON IT INTERNET
FRAUD PERSONNEL.
PERSONAL ASPECT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE.
GOVERNMENT IS ALWAYS THE BEST
THAT.
I HAD AT THESE
S. DATA SYSTEMS IN YOUR EYE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON. LIKE GANG LESS
WHAT WE KNOW PEOPLE BEEN PUT ON
IT THAT SHOULDN'T BE BE ON
INSULIN IN MANY WAYS I AGREE
WITH THE NRA THAT WE NEED TO. BE
VERY VIGILANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T PUT THE WRONG PEOPLE ON
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT OFF.
THEY HAVE THEIR THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT. GOOD TO TAKE THEMSELVES
OFTEN WE WE WE DO THAT LETTER OF
THEM REMOVE THEM. AND THEN
ANSWER THE OTHER QUESTION ABOUT
THE NEXT SYSTEM IN THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM.
AND I BELIEVE YOU WILL.
YOU WILL BE WILL DO THAT AND SO
I'M.
ALSO I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO TALK TO MR KILEY SO
THE TWO OF YOU TALK IN INDIA
MEMBERS LOUNGE I. THOUGHT YOU
HAD ANSWERED MOST OF HIS
QUESTIONS EVIDENTLY YOU DIDN'T
AND SEWER.
WELL I WOULDN'T TALKING IT I
WOULD URGE YOU TO TO CONTINUE
TALKING BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU YOU MADE SOME PROGRESS
S. WITH THEM. UP ON THAT ON THAT
FRONT.
AND SO IT WOULD DO WE GET.
A MOTION MAPPED SECTOR KALRA.
ON A. B. NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY
AYE AYE LACKEY AIKEN LEO. KALLIO
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
WHICH I KILEY.
KILEY NOT BOATING QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF
FOR CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I
MISSPOKE WHEN I TALKED ABOUT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON A. B..
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE QUIRK A.
B. NINETEEN NINETY FOUR SAVANT
IS A BE.
TWENTY SEVENTY EIGHT DALY AND AB
TWENTY EIGHTY CERVANTES I
MISSPOKE AND THEY ARE ON
CONSENT.
I GUESS THAT THEY WERE PULLED
THERE ARE CONSENT FOR MAKING
THAT CORRECTION.
THAT.
NO ONE WILL COME DOWN HERE.
SO MISTER QUIRK WOULD LIKE.
TO VOTE ON THOSE FOUR ITEMS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY WERE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO IS A MOTION THAT THOSE WHO
ARE THE FOUR ITEMS.
THEIR SECOND.
KALRA.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE.
LACKEY I'M LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
GOT A YEAR AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OF THE REMAINING
ITEMSON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
OF.
FRIEDMAN AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
THREE.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND SUGGESTIONS IT WAS VERY VERY
HELPFUL FOR US.
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE WOULD
WORKERS WHO WANT TO REPORT A
CRIME OF VIOLENCE PERPETRATED
AGAINST THEM DURING AN ACT
PROSTITUTION. OR WANT TO TESTIFY
AS A WITNESS TO SUCH A CRIME.
BY PROHIBITING EVIDENCE OF
CRIMINAL LIABILITY IN SUCH CASES
WERE REASSURING ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN OUR
STATE THAT THEY DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS EVERY OTHER
CALIFORNIAN.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS PROMOTED
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OF OUR STATE
BY ENCOURAGING EVERY VICTIM
EVERY WITNESS TO COME FORWARD.
HOWEVER SEX SEX WORKERS OFTEN
AVOID REPORTING CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST THEM BECAUSE THEY FEAR
BEING PROSECUTED FOR THEIR
PROSTITUTION.
AND A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO SAINT JAMES INFIRMARY
RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT OVER
SIXTY PERCENT OF SEX WORKERS
FACE SOME FORM OF ASSAULT WHILE
ENGAGING IN SEX WORK.
THIRTY TWO PERCENT REPORTED A
PHYSICAL ASSAULT WHILE TWENTY
NINE BEFORE FOR A REPORTED A
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
CURRENTLY MANY PROSECUTORS
PROVIDED UNITY THE SEX WORKERS
WHO ACT AS COOPERATING WITNESSES
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE WOULD
SIMPLY CODIFIED THIS PRACTICE.
WHICH IS COMMON.
THE SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
TURNING ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN. CRAFTED SIMILAR
POLICE POLICIES LAST YEAR AND A
SEEM ENCOURAGING RESULTS.
TESTIFYING TODAY IS MINISH
KENDELL THE WOMEN'S POLICY
DIRECTOR FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MEAN YOU
SCANDAL I'M THE WOMEN'S POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THAT DEPARTMENT THE
STATUS OF WOMEN FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO I WANNA
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
FOR CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. IN THIS ERA OF ME
TOO AND IT'S TIME AND WE SAID
ENOUGH WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WOMEN IN ALL INDUSTRIES AND
PROFESSIONS ARE PROVIDED A SAFE
ROUTE AND SUPPORTED IN REPORTING
SEXUAL. HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE
AND SEX WORKERS ARE SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE VICTIMS SUBJECT
TO EXTREMELY HIGH LEVELS OF
VIOLENCE AND ASSAULT. AND
BECAUSE SEX WORK IS CRIMINALIZED
ADDS AN EXTRA BARRIER FOR SEX
WORKERS TO COME FORWARD AND
REPORT BEING. ASSAULTED BECAUSE
THEY MAY FEAR THAT THEY MAY BE
ARRESTED.
THIS BILL WAS INSPIRED BY A
LOCAL POLICY AS WAS MENTIONED
THAT WE DEVELOPED IN SAN
FRANCISCO OUT OF OUR.
MAYOR'S TASK FORCE ON AND A
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH SEX WORKER
RIGHTS GROUPS AND ARE JUST
RETURNEES OFFICE IN OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT WE IMPLEMENTED THIS
POLICY LATE LAST YEAR AND WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN. THAT BENEFICIAL
RESULTS I WAS RECENTLY TALKING
TO AN INSPECTOR IN OUR SPECIAL
VICTIMS UNIT AT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT SAN FRANCISCO. AND HE
DESCRIBED A RECENT INCIDENT
WHERE A SEX WORKER WAS BRUTALLY
ASSAULTED AND STABBED ON A
STREET IN THE MISSION
NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND A NEIGHBOR HEARD HER
SCREAMING AND WANTED TO CALL
FOR.
AND AMBULANCE AND SHE REALLY
DIDN'T WANT HIM TO DO THAT
BECAUSE SHE WAS AFRAID SHE WAS
GOING TO GET ARRESTED AND WHEN
HE SAW HER BLEEDING HE INSISTED
AND WHEN THE POLICE SHOWED UP
AGAIN. SHE WAS VERY RELUCTANT TO
TELL THEM.
WHAT HAD HAPPENED WHO HAD DONE
THIS TO HER IN PART BECAUSE SHE
WAS BEING PROSECUTED IN ANOTHER
COUNTY FOR PROSTITUTION AND THE
OFFICERS LITERALLY TOLD HER
ABOUT THIS POLICY AND EVENTUALLY
WERE ABLE TO SHOW HER A WRITTEN
COPY OF THE POLICY? AND IT GAVE
HER COMFORT IN PROVIDING
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION WHICH
LED TO THE ARREST OF. THE.
THE PERPETRATOR SO.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN HOW HELPFUL
IT CAN BE TO HAVE A POLICY LIKE
THIS IN WRITING OR CODIFIED EVEN
IF IT IS THE ACTUAL PRACTICE FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
PRIORITIZE MORE SERIOUS CRIMES
SO. WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE WHICH
PROVIDES A WAY FOR SEX WORKERS
TO SAY ME TOO.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSE ALICE KESSLER ON
BEHALF OF A QUALITY CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KATIE MILLER ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY GEORGE GASTON STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MOVE THE BILL AND.
I WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
IS THERE SECOND.
THIS QUESTION ON THIS SO I'M.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE ACTUALLY ARE
QUITE A FEW TYPES OF LOW LEVEL
CRIMES THAT MAY TEND TO.
OCCUR A LOT AND THAT THE
PRESENCE OF A HIGHER LEVEL
CRIMES I MEAN YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GENERALLY TOOLS A PROSECUTORIAL
DISCRETION TO.
UNIFIED SOMEONE WITHOUT
IMMUNITY IF THEY COME FORWARD
AND TESTIFY FOR THE HIGHER CRIME
SO AND THIS IS THE KIND OF A
DIFFERENT APPROACH IN JUST THAT.
TOTAL ACROSS THE BOARD BAR ON
THE ADMISSIBILITY OF EVIDENCE IS
THERE ANY PRECEDENT FOR THIS AND
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS IS AN
APPROACH THAT IS NEEDED BEYOND
KIND OF THE EXISTING TOOLS THAT
PROSECUTORS HAVE.
I CAN'T SPEAK AS TO WHETHER
THERE'S A PRECEDENT BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT WE'VE CERTAINLY
HEARD FROM THE PROSECUTORS AND
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY
DO EXPERIENCE TIMES WHERE SEX
WORKERS ARE AFRAID TO. ON THE BE
A WITNESS OR TO COME FORWARD
ABOUT THEIR OWN VIOLENT CRIME
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE PROSECUTION.
SO WE DO KNOW THAT THAT IS A
BARRIER TO REPORTING AND SAID
YOU KNOW WHAT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AT THE COMPELLING.
CRIME THAT THEY WANT TO.
PREVENT ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMMITTING VIOLENT ACTS IN AND.
THAT'S THE YOU KNOW THE THE.
PUBLIC BENEFIT IF THIS IS REALLY
TO GET PEOPLE THAT ARE VIOLENT
SEXUAL PREDATORS AND VIOLENT
PREDATORS OFF THE STREETS AND IF
THERE'S A BARRIER LIKE THIS THAT
WE KNOW OF. I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO REMOVE THAT
BARRIER.
CAN I RESPOND BECAUSE ACTUALLY
IS A PRECEDENT.
IN THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING SPHERE
THERE'S AN EVIDENTIARY EXCLUSION
ABOUT EVIDENCE THAT SOMEONE THAT
A HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIM WAS
ENGAGED IN PROSTITUTION I'M
CANNOT BE USED AGAINST THEM IF
THE PROSTITUTION WAS A RESULT OF
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING SAID THERE
IS I'M A. VERY SIMILAR PRESIDENT
IS THAT A.
IS AN EVIDENTIARY BAR DOES IT
GO TO ASK WHETHER THE THE AN
ELEMENT OF THE OFFENSE WHEN YOU
HAVE IT AND IT'S IN THE EVIDENCE
CODE. YEAH AND THEN ON TO GET
YOUR POINT ABOUT DON'T
PROSECUTORS ALREADY HAVE TOOLS
IF PEOPLE ARE FREE TO REPORT IN
THE FIRST PLACE IT WON'T EVEN
GET TO THE PROSECUTOR'S DESK TO
OFFER THAT IMMUNITY AND THAT'S
WHAT WE SAW WE SAW IN THE CASE.
THAT I.
GAVE AN EXAMPLE OF IF THE
POLICE HADN'T BEEN ABLE TO
REASSURE THAT PERSON AT THE TIME
THEY WERE REPORTING ABOUT THIS
IT NEVER WOULD HAVE EVEN MADE IT
TO THE PROSECUTOR TO OFFER THAT
KIND OF IMMUNITY SO WE RELEASED.
SEE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IT
EARLIER ON IN THE PROCESS TO BE
SURE PEOPLE. KNOW IT BUT HELPFUL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
COLD OF.
I JUST ONE MORE COMMENT.
AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE BILL AND BE AT
BEING ADDED TO SCOTT WALKER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE HAPPY TO
DO THAT.
BURKE SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB TWENTY TO FORTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE LACKEY AYE
AYE LACKEY AYE CARILLO. CARILLO
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MR WOULD.
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN.
I HAVE A NOTE HERE.
THIS SAYS TESTIMONY ONLY.
UNDERSTOOD CRICKET OP.
BEFORE MAKE SURE ROZAY PAGE GET
GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
LATE ON THE NIGHT OF OCTOBER
EIGHTH LAST YEAR WILDFIRES RAGED
THROUGH NAPA CINEMA LAKE AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES AND LIVES
WERE FOREVER CHANGED.
THE FIRES THAT DESTROYED NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES AND CLEARLY
IN INCLUDING NEARLY SIX THOUSAND
HOMES IN MY DISTRICT ALONE.
THOUSANDS MY CONSTITUENTS LUSTER
OF HOMES THAT IN ONE NIGHT.
THE NIGHTMARE SCENARIO TOOK WHAT
WAS ALREADY A DIFFICULT HOUSING
MARKET AND TURNED IT INTO A
CRISIS.
THE NORTH A FIRESTORM BECAME
QUICKLY THE MOST EXPENSIVE
HISTORY AND IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE GOOD WORK OF MY COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING MANY OF YOU ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ENSURED THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE STRONG PRICE
GOUGING PROTECTIONS.
CURRENT LAW PREVENTS THE COST OF
ANY GOOD OR SERVICE INCLUDING
HOUSING OF FROM BEING RAISED
MORE THAN TEN PERCENT DURING TO
DECLARE DISASTER.
UNFORTUNATELY UNSCRUPULOUS
LANDLORDS AND VACATION RENTAL
HOST HAVE MANAGED TO SKIRT THESE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE. OF THOSE WHO LOST
EVERYTHING.
IN LESS THAN A WEEK THE MEDIAN
RENTAL RATE IN CINEMA COUNTY
JUMPED BY OVER THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT. THERE WERE DOZENS OF
EXAMPLES OF HOMES BEING OFFERED
FOR MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
PREVIOUS ASTOR PRICE OF SIMILAR
HOMES.
THIS HAPPENED BECAUSE CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE A METHOD
FOR DETERMINING THE BASE RENT OF
A HOME. AND THAT AND THAT WAS
NOT OF THAT WAS NOT ON THE
RENTAL MARKET BEFORE DECLARE
DISASTER.
AS A RESULT HOMEOWNERS WHO WHO
HAVE A SECOND HOME IN THE AREA.
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PUT THEIR
HOUSE ON THE MARKET PRETTY MUCH
WHATEVER PRICE THEY WANT.
WITH AN INFLUX A TEMPORARY
INSURANCE MONEY FOR TEMPORARY
LIVING EXPENSES AND THE LOSS OF
OVER FIVE PERCENT OF THE
COUNTIES HOUSING STOCK
OVERNIGHT.
MY DISTRICT IS BECOMEA PRIME
HUNTING GROUND FOR LANDLORDS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF FIRE VICTIMS.
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN CLOSES THE
NEW RENTAL LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING
LAW BY REDEFINING BASED READ AS
A HUNDRED SIXTY PERCENT OF THE
HUD FAIR MARKET VALUE. THIS
DEFINITION CLEAR PRO PROVIDES A
CLEARLY DEFINED NUMBER OF FOR
BOTH LANDLORDS AND TENANTS TO
ENSURE EVERYONE IS PLAYING BY
THE RULES.
I LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF OF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL. AND WHEN THE TIME
COMES SAYS VOTE FOR A VOTE ON IT
AT SOME POINT EVERY DAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
HERE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS.
OF THE BILL IS A SEMI COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY A MAC CHEEVER
AND CAROLINE FOWLER.
U. MORNING MY NAME'S MATT
CHEEVER I'M A I'M A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE CINEMA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE I PROMOTED HIM I'M SORRY.
YEAH THAT'S AS WELL TO GET THAT
MAKES PERFECT.
IT IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE FIRES
AND AND AND AND ACTUALLY WILL
SOME OF THE FIRES WERE STILL
BURNING OUR OFFICE DID EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH.
TO TRY TO GET THE WORD OUT TO.
REAL THE REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY
AND THE PUBLIC ABOUT PRICE
GOUGING TO TRY TO.
DO WE COULD TO DETER IT AND.
WE RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF PHONE
CALLS AND EMAILS FROM LANDLORDS
TENANTS PROPERTY MANAGERS
REALTORS.
YOU NAME IT ASKING WHAT THEY
COULDN'T COULDN'T DO WHAT THE
LAW ALLOWED.
THAT THERE WERE NUMEROUS
QUESTIONS.
AND WE ALSO RECEIVED HUNDREDS
OF COMPLAINTS WE INVESTIGATED
OVER TO OUR COMPLAINTS OF PRICE
GOUGING.
ALMOST ALL OF WHICH ARE RELATED
TO RENTAL HOUSING.
I AND WE THINK THAT THAT
NUMBER'S UNREPORTED WE THINK
THERE WERE MANY OF REPORTED
CASES BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO CALLED. WOULDN'T GIVE US
THEIR NAME CONTACT INFORMATION
OR OTHER INFORMATION WHEN
NEEDED.
TO DO AN INVESTIGATION BECAUSE.
FOR FEAR OF OF RETALIATORY
EVICTIONS.
SO FAR WE'VE FILED FOR CRIMINAL
CASES ARE STILL PENDING IN THE
COURTS AND WE HAVE.
AND MANY OTHER CASES THAT WERE
STILL REVIEWING FOR EITHER
CRIMINAL OR CIVIL ENFORCEMENT.
.
PEOPLE COULD SECTION THREE
NINETY SIX CURRENTLY LUMPS
RENTAL HOUSING AND WITH OTHER
CONSUMER GOODS OR SERVICES LIKE
BOTTLED WATER FOR EXAMPLE.
AND WE'VE LEARNED INVESTIGATING
IN REVIEWING THESE CASES THAT
THERE ARE SEVERAL UNIQUE ISSUES.
AND APPLYING TO APPLY THE
STATUTE TO RENTAL HOUSING.
THERE AREN'T ANY REPORTED CASES.
.
THAT INTERPRET THREE NINETY SIX
AND WHAT WE DISCOVERED OTHER IN
VERY FEW PROSECUTION STATEWIDE
UNDER THE STATUTE.
BEFORE THE DISASTERS THAT WERE
THAT WERE ADDRESSING NOW.
WE NEED CLEAR STANDARDS FOR REAL
ESTATE THE REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY
FOR LANDLORDS TENANTS.
AND FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DETER
PRICE GOUGING AND TO MAKE
PROSECUTIONS WORKABLE.
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD
CLARIFY CERTAIN ASPECTS OF PENAL
CODE SECTION THREE NINETY SIX AS
IT APPLIES TO HOUSING.
I WOULD EXTEND THREE NINETY SIX
IS A REACH TO A COUPLE OF
SITUATIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
COVERED.
AND I'LL TALK FIRST ABOUT WHERE
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE STATUE
EXTENDED.
OF THE CENTER OF THE PRESS
DEMOCRAT RAN A STORY SEVERAL
WEEKS AFTER THE FIRES THAT
ACCORDING TO ZILLOW MEDIAN RENTS
RENTS IN THE COUNTY. WERE UP
THIRTY SIX PERCENT.
THIS IS LARGE THIS WAS LARGELY
ATTRIBUTED TO NEW RENTALS ON THE
MARKET WHICH WERE. PROPERTIES
THAT ONLY CAME UP FOR RENT
AFTER.
THE FIRES.
AND FROM VACATION RENTALS THAT
WERE NOW BEING OFFERED ON A MORE
LONG TERM OR PERMANENT BASIS.
AND OUR VIEW PEOPLE CUT THREE
NINETY SIX ISN'T CURLY ADDRESS
ADDRESS THOSE SITUATIONS.
SO AFTER THE FIRE SOME PROPERTY
OWNERS RECOGNIZE THAT COULD PULL
THEIR HOMESTHAT WERE LISTED FOR
SALE OFF THE MARKET.
AND RENT THEM OUT INSTEAD FOR.
A VERY HIGH RENTS AND SINCE
THREE NINETY SIX DOZEN APPLIED
THESE DO RENTALS. THEY COULD
CHARGE WHATEVER THEY WANTED.
.
SIMILARLY VACATION RENTAL
OWNERS.
WHO HYPOTHETICALLY BEFORE THE
FIRE MIGHT'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CHARGE THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
NIGHT? AND MAYBE RENT THEIR
VACATION ROLL OUT TEN NIGHTS.
A MONTH.
EARNING YOU KNOW THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ROUGHLY.
BUT ABSENT THE FIRE THEY WERE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO CHARGE
NOTES TO EARN NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH AND A LONG TERM
LEASE.
SO THE SITUATION SKEWED THE
MARKET IS THE PRESS DEMOCRAT
ARTICLE EXPLAINS. AND ALSO REYES
BASIC FAIRNESS ISSUES ABOUT WHY
ONE LANDLORD COULD ONLY CHARGE
THREE OR FOUR DOLLARS A MONTH
AND THEIR NEIGHBOR MIGHT BE ABLE
TO CHARGE NINE HUNDRED NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
HYPOTHETICALLY.
BECAUSE OF THREE FOUR HUNDRED
AND IT THREE FOUR THOUSAND. AND
THE NEIGHBOR Y. PILCHARD NINE
THOUSAND.
IF IF THE.
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T WANT TO
DISCOURAGE FOLKS FROM PUTTING
ADDITIONAL HOUSING ON THE
MARKET.
PARTICULARLY WHEN THERE'S A
HOUSING SHORTAGE.
WE BELIEVE AB NINETEEN IN
NINETEEN WOULD PROVIDE A FAIR
RETURN PROPERTY OWNERS WHO.
WHO AREN'T ATTEMPTING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OF THE OF A
DISASTER?
AND EIGHT SO AB NINETEEN
NINETEEN WOULD OFFER WOULD GO TO
CLEAR MARKET MARKET STATE FAIR
MARKET STANDARD IN THE
SITUATIONS.
WHICH WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE FAIR MARKET
RATE IS ESTABLISHED BY HIDING IT
IS PUBLISHED ON THEIR ON HUD'S
WEBSITE.
AND NOT EASILY DETERMINABLE
NUMBER.
ITS EASY FOR LANDLORDS TO
FIGURE OUT ITS EASY FOR US AS
PROSECUTORS TO PROVE IF WE BRING
THESE CASES TO COURT.
AND THE NEXT YEAR I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ADDRESSED OR OF ACTIONS
BY LANDLORDS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
RAISING RENTS BY MORE THAN TEN
PERCENT.
ACCORDING TO LEGAL AID CINEMA
COUNTY SOUGHT TWENTY SIX PERCENT
INCREASE IN EVICTIONS POSE FIRE.
AND WE RECEIVED DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF COMPLAINTS FROM PEOPLE
WHO WERE EVICTED.
AND THEN SAW THEIR FORMER HOUSE
ADVERTISE THEIR MUCH HIGHER RATE
THAN MUCH HIGHER RENT THEM WHAT
THEY WERE PAYING.
WE'VE YOU THE SITUATIONS IS
MORE EGREGIOUS THAN NORMAL PRICE
GOUGING THE EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM BY. CREATING MORE
HOMELESS PEOPLE AND PUTTING
THOSE PEOPLE INTO THE HOUSING
MARKET.
AND FURTHER.
.
MAKING THE PROBLEM WORSE.
SO AB NINETEEN WOULD ADDRESS
THIS BY MAKING EVICTIONS UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNLAWFUL.
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER NOW TO MY
COLLEAGUE CAROLINE FOLLOWED FROM
MY OFFICE TO DISCUSS.
SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS THAT WE
THINK AB NINETEEN NINETEEN WOULD
CLARIFY THE PRICE GOUGING LAW.
THANK YOU CHAIR SIREN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THAT IS MR HUBER
INDICATED ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT A. B. NINETEEN
NINETEEN ATTEMPTS TO DO IS TO
CLARIFY FOR THOSE. PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO WERE ALREADY IN THE
RENTAL HOUSING MARKET HOW THIS
STATUTE APPLIES BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT IT'S CURRENTLY LUMPED
IN WITH GOODS AND SERVICES.
THEY'RE NOT VERY. CLEAR
ARTICULATE STANDARDS FOR THE
REALTORS FOR THE PROPERTY OWNERS
AND.
FOR THE TENANTS THAT WE'VE
RECEIVED IN THE LARGE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THESE CLARIFICATIONS. ADD TO
DEFINE IN THE CONTEXT OF HOUSING
WHAT THE BEFORE AND AFTER RENTAL
PRICES ARE BASED ON. WOULD
GREATLY ASSIST IN DETERRING THIS
AND ASSIST US IN HAVING TO BRING
PROSECUTIONS WHEN IT'S
NECESSARY.
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT THE
BILL WOULD DO IS ALSO CLARIFY
THAT WITHIN THE DEFINITION OF
RENTAL HOUSING IT COVERS MOBILE
HOME PARKS AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
WELL AWARE. I'M OUR MOBILE HOME
PARKS AT UP IN OUR HOMES TO MANY
SENIORS AND MANY LOW INCOME. AT
TENANTS WE HAVE SEEN INSTANCES
WHERE.
MOBILE HOME RIGHT SPACES HAVE
RECEIVED NOTICES IN ACCESS OF
THE TEN PERCENT INCREASE AND
BECAUSE THE PROPERTY OWNERS
BELIEVE THAT MOBILE HOMES ARE
NOT COVERED UNDER THE CURRENT
LAW. SO WE WOULD LIKE TO CLARIFY
THAT POINT.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE'VE FACED
IS THAT THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
HAVE COME IN AND RIGHTFULLY
TRYING TO PROTECT THEIR
INSURANCE AND GET THEM HOUSING
UNFORTUNATELY THAT HAS DRIVEN UP
THE MARKET. AND WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF JUSTIFICATION FROM
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT IT'S ONLY
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES SO WE'RE
NOT REALLY PRICE GOUGING.
BUT EVEN THOUGH THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE PAYING THE TAB IT
REALLY DOES HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE VICTIMS BECAUSE IT
DIMINISHES THEIR COVERAGE. SUCH
THAT THEIR REPLACEMENT HOUSING
MAY ONLY LAST FOR SIX MONTHS
INSTEAD OF A YEAR OR LONGER THAT
MAY TAKE FOR THEM TO REPLACE
THEIR HOUSING.
MORE IMPORTANTLY AT PRICES OUT
THOSE VICTIMS WHO ARE NOT
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE
INSURANCE WE HAD A LARGE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO WERE RANCHERS. AND
WHO LOST THEIR HOMES DURING THIS
FIRE AND THEY HAVE NO INSURANCE
AND THEY CAN'T COMPETE IF PEOPLE
ARE ALLOWED TO.
GO BEYOND THE PRICES THAT ARE
SET FORTH IN PENAL CODE SECTION
THREE NINETY SIX.
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGE WITH THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THREE NINETY SIX
THERE'S THERE'S A PROVISION THAT
ALLOWS.
AND THE SELLER OF GOODS TO THAT
WERE ON SALE IMMEDIATELY PRIOR
TO THE EMERGENCY DEBATE THE TEN
PERCENT INCREASE ON THE REGULAR
PRICE OF THE GOOD. SILVA BOTTLED
WATER WAS ON SALE FOR A DOLLAR
NINETY FIVE MINUTES NORMALLY TO
FIFTY. AND THE SELLER CAN GO
BACK TO THE TWO FIFTY PER PRICE
AND THEN INCREASE IT BY TEN
PERCENT. AND WE'VE RECEIVED
ARGUMENTS FROM OWNERS THAT THIS
MEANS THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO RETURN THEIR PROPERTY TO FAIR
MARKET VALUE IF IT WAS.
AND I DON'T BELOW MARKET RATE BE
PRIOR TO THE EMERGENCY. THIS
CREATES A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
STANDARD TO DETERMINE WHAT
SHOULD BE THE FAIR MARKET RENTAL
IN THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES. THOSE
MISTER CHEEVER SAID WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR IS A FAIR EASILY
DETERMINABLE RATE THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE TO THE PUBLIC TO
THE REAL ESTATE COMMUNITY AND TO
THE PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE
REAL ESTATE INDUSTRY THE
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY
THEY'VE WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
US TO EDUCATE THEIR MEMBERS AND
I THINK THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING
FOR A COMMON GOOD OF TRYING TO
MAKE IT CLEAR LAW. THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS.
AND WE WITH THANK YOU AND
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT ON AB
NINETEEN NINETEEN THANK THANK
YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT NAME IN.
ORGANIZATION YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN A DEBRA
CARL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
AND THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL CLARITY WE APPRECIATE
THE CLARIFICATION THAT WE HAVE
SO FAR. THANK YOU.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
IN SUPPORT.
BOOKS.
IT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DANVILLE
ASSAULT ON HALF A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IT'S PART.
THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS GONZALEZ OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYWHERE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WHAT TAKE A SEAT?
I'M CATHERINE OR WITH THE
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES WERE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR TO DEAL WITH THE UP
THE MOBILE HOME PARK SPACES.
MOST OF NOT ALL THOSE SPACES ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER RENT CONTROL SO
THE TEN PERCENT MAYBE.
VERY LOW IF SOMEBODY HAS BEEN
THERE FOR TWENTY YEARS AND NOW
SPACE.
WHAT OF NORMALLY GONE UP?
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM ON
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A CREAM GREASY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OVER CURRENTLY AN IN
BETWEEN A POSITION WE WERE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. ON.
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY AMONG
OTHER THINGS THAT A LANDLORD MAY
STILL OF TENANT FOR NON PAYMENT
OF RENT A DURING THE TIME PERIOD
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL.
SO I BELIEVE THOSE AMENDMENTS
BEING TAKEN TODAY IN COMMITTEE
AND WE DO WANT TO SINCERELY
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THAT ONE ONCE WAS
AMENDMENTS ARM PRINT WE WILL BE
MOVING TO A NEUTRAL POSITION.
THANK YOU.
SO ARE YOU BOTH TWEENER.
OKAY.
OFFICIAL TERMINOLOGY HERE.
MAYBE.
ADDICT.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
DIRT KILEY VERY INQUISITIVE
TODAY.
SO I I YOU KNOW WE COULD HAVE A
GOOD DEBATE AS TO WHETHER I THE
SORT OF RESTRICTIONS ARE THAT
* MOST EFFICIENT ARE MOST
HUMANE WAY TO RESPOND CONDITIONS
OF OF TEMPORARY SCARCITY BUT I.
THE QUESTION I WOULD ASK IS IS
THE.
IS IS USING THE CRIMINAL LAW
AND THE SORT OF CIRCUMSTANCES
AND NOTICED THE SUPPORT FOR SOME
D. A.'S HERE I AND I HEAR WHAT
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WHY
ARE WE TREATING THE PENALTIES Y.
ARE MAKING MORE THINGS ILLEGAL.
OUT WIRE WIRE CIVIL PENALTIES
AND NOT ADEQUATE TO ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVES YOU WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH AND WHY DO WE HAVE
TO.
TRY TO CRIMINALIZE WHAT WOULD
ORDINARILY BE JUST TYPICAL
MARKETPLACE ACTIVITY.
WELL. SO PEOPLE COULD THREE
NINETY SIX IS THAT RT PROVIDES
THE CRIMINAL LIABILITY IN THIS
IN THIS AREA.
BUT IT DOES ALSO MAKE.
THESE VIOLATIONS UNLAWFUL.
UNDER BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE SEVENTEEN TO HUNDREDS OF
THE CIVIL ENFORCEMENT THAT YOU.
SO I THINK I THINK THE ANSWER
IS.
BUT THIS ATTORNEYS HAVE
DISCRETION TO BRING THESE
ACTIONS EITHER CRIMINAL OR CIVIL
E. BASED ON.
A NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT
HEMINGWAY WHEN WHEN REVIEWING A
CASE IN DETERMINING WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE RESOLUTION WOULD.
AT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA TRY TO CREATE NEW LAW
WE'RE TRYING TO.
MODIFY EXISTING LAW AND THE
CRIMINAL THE CRIMINAL PENALTIES
ARE ALREADY THERE.
I THINK IT DOES EXTEND THEM TO
ENCOMPASS THE AREAS THAT NOW
YOU'RE BRINGING ON IBM BUT IF
THAT IS RIGHT NOT JUST WATCHING
EXPANSION CURRENT LAW CORRECT
YEAH SO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON
THAT MISTER WHAT AND WHY IS IT
THAT WE NEED TO. USE THE
CRIMINAL LAW HERE.
RATHER THAN JUST THE CIVIL
PENALTIES THAT ARE ALSO THAT
WELL I WOULD SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW I.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT IS THE
A DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO
HAVE DISCRETION I THINK THERE
ARE SOME THAT ARE REALLY REALLY
EGREGIOUS AND I THINK THOSE ARE
DESERVE OF A HIGHER POTENTIAL
PENALTY QUITE FRANKLY.
I THINK IT ALSO CREATES A
GREATER DETERRENT FOR THOSE THAT
ARE INCLINED TO DO IT AS OPPOSED
TO JUST FACTORING IN THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS.
TO JUSTIFY THEM JACKING UP THEIR
RATES TO HIGH RATE AND THEN DEAL
WITH THAT LATER ECONOMICALLY
RATHER THAN. HAVING A THREAT OF
A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING AGAINST
THEM.
YEAH SO I SEE YOUR POINT I MEAN
JUST SEEMS THAT THE WHOLE POINT
OF THESE ACTORS DOING THIS IS TO
YOU KNOW MAXIMIZE THEIR PROFITS
AND IF YOU KNOW YOU HAVE CIVIL
PENALTIES THAT OUR MONETARY
NATURE THAT WOULD.
COUNTERACT THAT BENEFIT THEM
THAT THAT SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT
RENT ME OUR HOPE IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS TO TURN IN AN
IDEAL WORLD WE WOULD LIKE TO NOT
EVER HAVE TO TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S
BEEN. VERY DIFFICULT HAVING TO
LISTEN TO THE VICTIMS OF THE
FIRE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND SO WE FEEL
THAT THERE IS A GREATER
DETERRENT EFFECT.
DO YOU HAVE THE CRIMINAL.
PROCESS THAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND.
YOU MAY.
CONCLUDE.
HUESO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THINK FOR THE QUESTIONS THIS IS
AN ACUTE PROBLEM IN IN OUR AREA
AND.
AND WE WANNA BE SURE THAT IN
THE FUTURE OTHER OTHER AREAS DO
NOT EXPERIENCE THE SAME SAME
KIND OF ISSUE AT THE END OF THE
DAY.
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE PAYING
FOR A LOT OF A LOT OF THESE.
HOMES THAT HAVE BEEN RENTED AT
REALLY REALLY HIGH RATES AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE AS
CONSUMERS WILL PAY FOR THAT.
IN IN HIGHER PREMIUMS FOR FOR
INSURANCE AS WELL IN THE
MEANTIME.
THAT THE CONSUMER LOSES UMP THE
RENTAL MARKET IS ALREADY
EXTREMELY TIGHT. AND.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO GIVE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE
DISCRETION BILL TO GO AFTER THE
MOST EGREGIOUS ACTORS HERE. AND.
HOPEFULLY I CHANGE BEHAVIOR AND
PROTECT OUR CITIZENS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
THEY GOT IN A NOTICES FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT I WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR. WE JUST RAN OUT OF
TIME. WERE WORD SMITHING ON THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW WHERE. WE'RE
SO CLOSE IT.
WE COULD BE BACK VERY SOON AND
SO ANYONE THAT HAS ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS I WOULD
GET TO MISTER WOULD AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WHERE THAT
CLOSE.
ON TO COMING BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH I THINK YOU'LL
ENJOY.
TOM BUT AYE RECOMMENDATION SO.
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ONLY AND WILL HOPEFULLY WE'LL
SEE YOU BACK REAL SOON THANK YOU
ARE SEARCHING CHAIR WILL SEE IT
WOULD JUST VOTE ON IT WENT OKAY.
I'LL BE HERE TO WATCH THE VOTE
TO BE HERE TO WATCH THE VOTE.
MR VOEPEL WHO'S BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING FOR.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
VOEPEL ROGER THAT SERVE MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES I
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT TO YOU AID
BE. TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE THAT
ENABLES VEHICLE RENTAL COMPANIES
TO REPORT THEFT AS VEHICLES
BECOME OVER DO.
RATHER THAN BEING REQUIRED TO
WAIT FIVE DAYS AFTER THE AGREED
UPON VEHICLE RETURN DAY.
VEHICLE THEFT IS UNIQUE IN THE
SENSE THAT ANY WASTED TIME IN
THE REPORTING PROCESS ALLOWS THE
CRIMINAL TO FURTHER.
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISCONNECT FROM
THE SCENE.
MOTIVATION FOR AUTOMOBILE THEFT
IS HIGHER WHEN THERE WAS A FIVE
DAY GRACE PERIOD GIVEN. LEAVING
PLENTY OF TIME TO FLEE THE SCENE
AND DISMEMBER THE VEHICLE FOR
THE SALE OF PARTS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE RENTAL
COMPANY AND THE PERSON PRESUMED
TO BE STEALING THE CAR. VIA CELL
PHONE TELEPHONE TAX ACCEPT IRA
AND WHATEVER FUTURE TECHNOLOGY
MAY COME.
AND IF LEFT UNRESPONSIVE THROUGH
A MAIL NOTICE SNAIL MAIL NOTICE
IN ORDER TO MINIMIZE
MISUNDERSTANDINGS.
WHEN FRAUD IS DISCOVERED IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
BE NOTIFIED IMMEDIATELY RATHER
THEM WAITING UNTIL THE FIVE DAYS
EXPIRE AFTER THE EXPIRATION OF
THE CAR RENTAL LEASE.
COLLEAGUES ASK YOU THAT TODAY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT SIMPLY
EXPEDITED IMPROVES THE SYSTEM OF
TRACKING DOWN STOLEN CARS. THIS
EMPOWERS THE PROTECTION OF
PERSONAL VEHICLE PROPERTY AND
ENABLES THAT SECURITY IS NO
DIFFERENT. THAN THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ALREADY EXIST AROUND ANY
OTHER FORM OF CAPITAL.
AND THE AMENDMENTS DO YOU.
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENT.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE NEED YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGE AT
RISK YES SIR.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES.
SUPPORT.
OF THERE IS NO OPPOSITION THAT
I'M AWARE OF AND I DIDN'T WANT
TO WASTE THE COMMITTEES
TARNISHES IN SUPPORT. THE MAC IS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT NO YOU GO. AHEAD OF
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SHARKEY WOULD WANNA WITH
PENTAGON VAN RENTALS.
HERE IN SUPPORT.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES THAT
OPPOSITION.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NOT TAKEN
A POSITION ON THE BILL BUT JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS THAT BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS.
WORKING WITH US ON SOME
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD AND LOOK
FORWARD TO.
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THOSE
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU THAT THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
A.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE BILL.
SEC DID YOU.
I JUST HAVE A QUESTION I AM IS
THIS A BIG PROBLEM BECAUSE
UNLIKE OTHER THEFTS LIKE.
IN CAR RENTAL WE KNOW WHO THE
PERSON IS WHO IS RENTING A CAR
CRACKED.
CORRECT IS ONLY AS THEIR PRESENT
DEAN.
ACCURATE AND TRUE IDENTIFICATION
EXCEPT FOR ALSO YOU HAVE.
IN INSURANCE ISSUE IN THE SENSE
THAT SOMETIMES PEOPLE WHO ARE
LEGALLY RENTING CARS.
WILL. WORK AT LEAST ONE THEFT SO
THEY DON'T ESTABLISH A PATTERN.
AND WORK OUT A DEAL WITH
WHOEVER'S CHOP IN THE CAR SO I
MEAN THERE THERE IS THIS IS A. A
VIABLE.
NOT GREAT LEAD. BURNING NEED TO
NEED BUT IT IS GOOD ESPECIALLY
WITH THE NEW TECHNOLOGY.
TO KEEP TRACK OF RENTAL FLEETS.
BUT ANY OTHER WITNESS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MISTER QUIRK.
SO.
I THINK FORTY EIGHT HOURS IS A
MINIMUM AMOUNT OF TIME.
I WOULDN'T HAVE CONCERNED IF IT
WENT TO THREE DAYS HERE FOR
ABOUT.
I'M OKAY WITHOUT TWO DAYS.
.
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE SOMEBODY
HOLDING THE CAR OVER TWO DAYS IN
NOT REPORTING THAT SAM OKAY WITH
THAT.
WE HAVE AN INCONSISTENCY YEAR
IN THAT YOU CAN'T USE THE GPS TO
TRACK THE CAR FOR A WEEK.
ARM IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO WORK OUT
SOMETHING AS YOU GO INTO IT IF
THE BILL MAKES IT TO THE SENATE.
I WOULD SUGGEST DISCUSSING THAT
WITH.
.
AS A POSSIBLE AMENDMENT IN THE
SENATE TO ALLOW GPS TRACKING
ONCE THE CAR HAS BEEN REPORTED
AS HIM BASALT AS YOU DISCUSS.
THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY. YOU MAKE CONCLUDE.
GOOD TO VOTE YES PLEASE.
WE HAVE A MOTION JESSICA.
CALL NOW HONORED OLDER RIGHT
PATIENTS YES ON AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
I GOT VIDEO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE THAT IS
YOUR PATH
THAT MEASURE PRESSES
CONGRADULATIONS.
MISTER WEINER.
S. B..
SEVEN EIGHT FIVE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE
.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GREAT.
I MISSED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR HEARING
THIS BILL TODAY.
I SB SEVENTY FIVE I DON'T BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFFS.
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL
AND A LAST WEEK WE DID PUT
AMENDMENTS ACROSS THAT REFLECT
THE. COMMITTEES ARE.
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS TO THOSE
SHOULD ALL BE IMPRINT OUT BEFORE
YOU. ARE TODAY.
SP SEVENTY FIVE.
IS THEY ARE PROCEDURAL CHANGE
THE EVIDENCE CODE.
TO PREVENT IRRELEVANCE
INFORMATION ABOUT A WITNESSES
IMMIGRATION STATUS OPERA BEING
MENTIONED IN OPEN COURT.
ODDLY VERY CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT.
EXCLUDE ANY EVIDENCE THEIR OTHER
LOOK.
LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
DIED.
INDICATE WHEN IMMIGRATION STATUS
IS RELEVANT OR IRRELEVANT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
CHANGE THE ADMISSIBILITY OR LACK
THERE OF. OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
ALL IT DOES IS CREATE A
PROCEDURAL PROTECTION. AYE SO
THAT WHEN IMMIGRANT IS
TESTIFYING.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A PROFFER
FIRST TO THE JUDGE TO SHOW THE
ADMISSIBILITY OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS BEFORE YOU JUST BLURTED
OUT IN COURT.
I THIS IS A VERY REAL ISSUE WE
ARE SEEING OP I IMMIGRANTS ON
THE STAND.
BEING GRATUITOUSLY QUESTION HEY
WHAT'S YOUR IMMIGRATION STATUS
AYE EVEN IF IT HAS NO
CONCEIVABLE RELEVANCE
IMMIGRATION STATUS CAN BE
RELEVANT UNDER SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES. I UP TO GO IN A
CRIMINAL CASE TO SHOW BIAS.
BY ANOTHER AND OTHER SITUATIONS
IT'S COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT AND
IT ADMISSIBLE.
AND SO WE ARE SIMPLY SAYING
THAT IF AN ATTORNEY WANTS TO
QUESTION. AND IMMIGRANT ABOUT
HIS OR HER IMMIGRATION STATUS.
YOU HAVE TO GO IN CAMERA WITH
THE JUDGE MAKE A PROPER.
IS WHAT I WANT TO ASK I AM THIS
IS WHY I BELIEVE IT'S
ADMISSIBLE.
AND THE JUDGE WILL THEN MAKE A
RULING AND IF THE JUDGE RULES
IT'S ADMISSIBLE YOU GO BACK OUT
IN THE OPEN COURT AND YOU ASKED
THE QUESTION. THIS IS VERY
SIMILAR IT'S ESSENTIALLY
IDENTICAL TO THE PROCEDURE THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN RAPE CASES ARE
WHERE IF YOU HAVE.
DE VICTIM ON THE STAND AS AN
ATTORNEY YOU CAN'T JUST GO UP
AND START QUESTIONING THE
WITNESS THE WITNESS ABOUT HIS OR
HER SEXUAL HISTORY. YOU FIRST
HAVE TO GO AND MAKE A PROFFER TO
THE JUDGE.
ABOUT WHY IT'S ADMISSIBLE AND
THE JUDGE WILL THEN MAKE A
RULING. ON THIS HAS A REAL.
CONSEQUENCES
ALONE WE START HAVING HARASSING
AND GRATUITOUS IN A RELEVANT
QUESTIONING OF IMMIGRANTS ON THE
STAND ABOUT THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. OUGHT WE WANT PEOPLE TO
FEEL SAFE.
GOING TO QUIRK.
I AND WHAT IF THE MINUTE THAT
IMMIGRANTS.
I THINK THAT IF I GO TOO COR I'M
GONNA BE ASKED ABOUT MY
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND I MIGHT
GET DEPORTED.
THERE NOT GONNA GO TO QUIRK
THAT ARE GOING TO REPORT CRIMES
ARE NOT GOING TO SHOW UP AT
TESTIFIES VICTIM OR AS A WITNESS
AND WE WILL ALL BE LESS SAFE. WE
KNOW THAT I USE IS IN OUR COURT
HOUSES OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES HAS TOLD US
THAT WHEN OUR CHIEF JUSTICE.
OUR YOU WHO A REPUBLICAN
APPOINTED BY REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
ASKED THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT
TO DO THAT STOP STALKING PEOPLE
IN OUR. COURTHOUSES AND JEFF
SESSIONS RESPONDED.
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN THE COURT
HOUSES.
AND WHILE WE CAN'T PHYSICALLY
STOP THEM ALTHOUGH THERE IS A
BILL ON THAT.
WE CAN AT LEAST MAKE SURE THAT
OUR ATTORNEYS.
ARE NOT.
.
CAUSING IMMIGRANTS TO BE FEARFUL
OUGHT TO GO TO COURT.
WE HAVE.
WORKED EXTENSIVELY ON THIS BILL
WE DID HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN THE SENATE WITH THE I
BELIEVE THIRTY TWO VOTES IF MY
MEMORY SERVES.
AND WE HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY
WITH THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
WITH.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
WITH THE NEWSPAPER EDITORS AND
WE TAKE IN NUMEROUS.
AMENDMENTS.
I'M I DO WANT TO KNOW.
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS JUST.
CAME OUT I THINK LAST WEEK
AGAINST THE BILL I'M NOT THEY'RE
NOT AGAINST OUR PHILOSOPHICALLY
AGAINST THE BILL.
BUT THEY WANT US TO PUT AN
AMENDMENT IN ABOUT.
MAKING ABOUT BRADY.
OBLIGATIONS
CLUB THE BILL IS VERY CLEAR THAT
IT IS NOT IN ANY WAY CHANGE
DISCOVERY OBLIGATION SO IT WOULD
BE SUPERFLUOUS TO PUT THAT AND.
AND WE WE ACTUALLY TALK TO
COMMITTEE STAFF ABOUT THAT I
BELIEVE WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT
THAT THIS IS NOT. IN THE
EVIDENCE CODE THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO BE PUTTING.
RULES ABOUT BRADY OBLIGATIONS
DOES EXIST AND THE BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE OUR.
NOT IN ANY WAY.
I DO.
WANT TO NOTE THAT SINCE WE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK SOME AMERICANS OFF
FLETCHER FOR PARTNERING WITH US
ON THE BILL. SINCE WINS
INTRODUCED THAT ARE WATCHING AND
STAY ADOPTED A SIMILAR RULE AS A
RULE OF COURT.
SO I COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
AND I WANT TO.
TURNED OVER TO MY TWO WITNESSES
TODAY CHRIS SANCHEZ I WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND KATIE MILLER ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE I I REALLY WANT TO THANK
SENATOR WIENER FOR HIS SUPPORT
AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS. VERY
IMPORTANT BILL TO OUR OFFICE I'M
WITH THE CLIMATE OF FEAR IN OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
RAISING THE AND THE STATUS OF
THURMOND IMMIGRATION INQUIRED IF
IT'S NOT RELEVANT TO THE CASE IS
REALLY DONE FOR NO PURPOSE OTHER
THAN TO DISSUADE ARE VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES FROM FEELING
COMFORTABLE PARTICIPATING IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND MAYOR A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN OUR ABILITY TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN BOTH PROSECUTION
AND DEFENSE OF CASES.
AND WE KNOW THAT HAVING FOLKS
COME FORWARD WHEN THERE'S A
CRIME AS THE SENATOR SAID REALLY
PROMOTES COMMUNITY SAFETY. AND
AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE LOOKED AT SOME DATA IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
SAN FRANCISCO. OF REPORTS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENTS AND
WE SAW SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
OUR ASIAN AND LATINO COMMUNITIES
SO IT'S JUST A SIGN OF HOW I
THINK IN THE CURRENT CLIMATE
FOLKS ARE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
COMING FORWARD AND BEING PART OF
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. I'M WHEN
IMMIGRATION IS AN ISSUE FOR
THEM.
A WE ARE PLEASED TO.
TO BE A PART OF THIS BILL WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT WE THINK IT
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
ABILITIES AGAIN BUT TO PROSECUTE
CASES BUT ALSO IN THE BUILDING A
DEFENSE TO BRING IN WITNESSES
WHEN THEY NEED TO. HOOK HIM HAVE
A ROLE TO PLAY IN BUILDING THEIR
CASE. AND I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
OUR PUBLIC DEFENDER IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAS SUPPORTED THE
SPELL.
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE AWARE
OF THAT AS WELL SIR THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHAIR OF THE
COALITION FOR ME IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE I JUST LIKE ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT I AYE
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN JANUARY I
SENT OUT A DIRECTIVE ARE
REGARDING THE POLICY THAT THE
AGENT SHOULD BE HAVING WHEN
ENTERING COURTROOMS AND
APPREHENDING INDIVIDUALS.
THE DIRECTIVE CLEARLY STATES
THAT THEY SHOULD BE TARGETING
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS HOWEVER ARE
WE KNOW THE ICE AGENTS HAVE BEEN
WAITING OUTSIDE COURT ROOMS. ARE
AS A RESPONSE TO THIS OUR
DIRECTIVE AS THEY. ARE NO LONGER
BEING TOLD TO PICK UP ANYONE ON.
A IN THE CALL INSIDE THE
COURTROOM HOWEVER OUTSIDE THE
COURTROOM WE HAVE REPORTS OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN QUOTE UNQUOTE
STOCKED OUTSIDE THE COURTROOMS
ARE WHEN SOMEONE MIGHT BE
RELEASED OUR FIRST YOU KNOW
THEM.
THERE'S NO CHARGE OR THEY'RE NOT
ARRESTED THERE'S JUST OUTLINED
FOR HEARING AND AS THEY COME OUT
OF THE COURTROOM VIENEN ARE
DETAINED BY ICE.
HA SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
HIGHLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THREE
I'VE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES SUPPORT NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAFF
ASSAULT ON BEHALF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S PRESENTING ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
ARMENIANS ARE MILEY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CAROLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN PUT IN SUPPORT TICKET.
TALK.
NICHOLAS GONZALEZ FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT.
YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES ARE YOU
BETWEEN.
THAT CHAIR MEMBERS TAMPON FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
AS THE SENATOR INDICATED WE
HAVE WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
HIM HIS STAFF THE SPONSORS A AND
COMMITTEE STEFAN. AT THE MOST
RECENT ROUND OF AMENDMENTS WHICH
MAKES THE BILL MUCH MORE
WORKABLE FOR THE COURTS AND WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS WE NOW HAVE NO
POSITION TO REMOVE OUR PRIOR
CONCERTS THANK. THANK YOU.
WHAT WILL YOU?
IF YOU CAME HERE TWEENER IT
MILLION DO NOW.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERS ACROSS
YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE HERE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF COOL DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS. IN PRIVATE PRACTICE
ALSO WORKING PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICES.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL YET WE'VE
BEEN IN COMMUNICATION WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE SINCE LAST YEAR
THROUGHOUT LAST YEAR. ON THIS
BILL SOME OF OUR CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED OTHER STILL SOME
A FEW THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO WORK OUT.
BEEN A COMMUNICATIONS OFFICER
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
.
TWO THINGS WE DO TAKE ISSUE WITH
REPRESENTATION THAT FROM A
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS ARE. A
GRATUITOUSLY ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS AND COR ARE MEMBERS WE
SURVEYED A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS WE
DON'T BELIEVE THIS IS HAPPENING
AT LEAST WITH OUR MEMBERS I JUST
WANNA PUT THAT ON THE RECORD.
HOWEVER WE DO WORK A LOT ON
THESE IMMIGRATION ISSUES WE'VE
COSPONSORED. BILLS WITHOUT WITH
SOME OF THE PROPONENTS.
HERE WE DO WITH THE.
SOME WOMAN GONZALEZ FLETCHER
WERE WORKING ON BILL RIGHT NOW
SO WE'RE VERY SENSITIVE TO THAT
AND ALSO WE THINK IT'S.
UNFORTUNATE THAT WITH ICE GOING
TO COURT HOUSES THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THAT THAT'S HOW WE LOOK
AT THIS BILL BUT WE STILL THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE OF PROCEDURAL
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE.
CLARIFIED I DO APPRECIATE AND
REALLY LIKE THE AMENDMENTS BUT
PUT FORTH BY THE COMMITTEE TO
WILL CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS
ARE HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK.
SOMETHING OUT GOING FOR.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JIM E.
WERE WITH A CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATE WE HAVEN'T GOT TO A
POINT YET WHERE.
WERE OFF THE BILL.
BUT I I DO WANT TO INFORM THE
COMMITTEE ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE AND WHY WE
ARE STILL OPPOSED.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE AN
AUTOMATIC GAG ORDER FOR ANY
PARTICIPANT IN A CIVIL OR
CRIMINAL PROCEEDING.
AND THAT DOES NOT MEET THE
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS CREATED
BY THE U. S. SUPREME COURT FOR.
PROCEEDINGS IN BOTH A CIVIL OR
CRIMINAL CONTEXT.
THERE IS A PRESUMPTIVE RIGHT OF
ACCESS THAT THE PUBLIC HAS TO
DIS TYPES OF PROCEEDINGS.
AND.
THAT CAN BE OVERCOME WHEN IT
CAN BE SHOWN THAT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO CLOSE
EVEN PARTIALLY.
FOR A MORE COMPELLING INTEREST
AND IT MAY VERY WELL BE THAT.
THE ADMISSIBILITY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S IMMIGRATION STATUS
MEETS THAT STANDARD. ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS AND UNDER THE
EXISTING RULES RIGHT NOW WE
THINK THAT THAT WORKS WELL.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS.
A PROBLEM WITH.
THESE ROUTINE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS THAT ARE AGREED TO
INITIALLY BEING MADE.
EXISTING ONE NOW PROVIDES THAT
THE ATTORNEY WHO.
.
OUR FEELS THAT WAY CAN OBJECT
AND THEN GO BEFORE THE JUDGE AND
THAT DETERMINATION CAN BE MADE
AT THAT POINT BUT IT'S IN AN
OPEN COURTROOM.
.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A PER
SE BAN ON THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
SEE THE PROBATIVE VALUE OF THE
JUDGE'S QUESTIONS ON THE
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND THAT CAN BE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
WITNESSES.
AND THE HIGH PROFILE TRIALS EVEN
ON THERE WAS A SITUATION IN
ORANGE COUNTY WHERE THIS ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF WAS PLANTING JAIL
INFORMANTS.
ARE IN ORDER TO EXTRACT CERTAIN
TESTIMONY FROM ALLEGED
DEFENDANTS IN THEIR CUSTODY.
AND THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT THE
PUBLIC FROM SEEING THE JUDGES.
ARE PROBING OF THOSE WITNESSES
WITH RESPECT TO THE IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
WE WOULD ALL BE DONE BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
MOREOVER WE DON'T THINK THAT
DECISIONS THE OBJECTIVE THAT IT
STATED TO CHIEF ARM BECAUSE.
IT'S NOT GONNA PROVIDE A LEVEL
OF COMFORT TO THOSE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED COMING FORWARD
BECAUSE THERE'S STILL THE
POSSIBILITY EVEN IN THIS
PROCEEDING.
THAT THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
WILL COME OUT AND IF THAT'S THE
CASE THEN. ARMED THERE STILL NOT
GOING TO WANT TO COME FORWARD AS
A PARTICIPANT IN THE PROCESS.
AND.
IN DOING SO ARE HOWEVER THE
JUDICIAL IN THE. INTEGRITY OF
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS WILL BE
COMPROMISED AND WE JUST DON'T
THINK THAT THAT IS.
ENOUGH.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE'RE POST
FINICKY.
ANY OTHER WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING GUS HERE AM I DS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDER ASSOCIATION AND
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR WE ARE FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL. AND FOR.
AND WE HOPE TO MOVIE FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK. IN PROTECTING
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS ARE BOTH
VERY VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
OBVIOUSLY.
WE ARE CONCERNED. IT'S NOT SO
MUCH THE PROCEDURAL ASPECT IN
TERMS OF WHAT COMES IN DURING
THE PROCEEDINGS WE ARE MUCH MORE
CONCERNED WITH WHAT WE GET
BEFORE THOSE PROCEEDINGS.
BECAUSE OUR EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
THAT THERE'S BEEN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF CONFUSION REGARDING
THE PROTECTIONS SURROUNDING THE
U. VISA WHICH IS AN IMMIGRATION
BENEFIT THAT IS ONLY AVAILABLE
FOR INDIVIDUALS. WHO HAVE?
PARTICIPATED AND WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY RECEIVED A CERTIFICATE
OF REHABILITATION I'M SORRY. A
CERTIFICATE OF HELPFULNESS FROM
THE PROSECUTING AGENCY OR THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WHICH IS
A PREREQUISITE BEFORE PERSON CAN
EVEN APPLY FOR THIS IMMIGRATION
BENEFIT.
SO WHAT WE WANT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOT WITHSTANDING PILL COULD
SECTION SIX SEVENTY NINE ELEVEN
WHICH PER FOUGHT PROVIDES THE
PROCEDURES FORGETTING THAT
CERTIFICATION WITHIN NINETY DAYS
THAT IF A PERSON HAS RECEIVED
THIS CERTIFICATION.
NOTWITHSTANDING SOME OF THE THAT
THERE SOME CONFUSING LANGUAGE IN
SOME SIX SEVENTY NINE POINT
ELEVEN AND IN MY OPINION THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S CURRENTLY
CONTAINED. AND AS THE STATUTE IS
PRESENTLY DROPPED IT IS
INSUFFICIENT TO PUT MAKE SURE
THAT PROSECUTORS AND JUDGES AND
FRANKLY EVEN DEFENSE COUNSEL
UNDERSTAND. THAT
THE RULES INVOLVING DISCOVERY
AND BRADY ARE APPLICABLE EVEN IN
THESE SITUATIONS
AND I FEAR THAT IF WE DON'T GET
THE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE THAT WE
HAVE DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY WITH.
SENATOR WIENER STAFF MEMBERS
THAT WE WILL NOT GET THAT
INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE.
WE HAD A CLIP WE HAD A CLIENT IN
LOS ANGELES AND THIS WOMAN WAS A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SHE ONE DAY DEFENDED HERSELF
AND HER HUSBAND HER ABUSIVE
HUSBAND WAS ENTERED IN THE
PROCESS.
NOW.
AS A RESULT OF THESE INJURIES
SHE WAS CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND IT WAS NOT INTO HELL WE WERE
ABLE TO RECEIVE THE INFORMATION
REGARDING HIS APPLICATION AND
HIS STATEMENT IN SUBMITTING THE
U. VISA APPLICATION. THAT WE
FOUND OUT THAT HIS STORY HAD HAD
THAT HIS VERSION OF WHAT HE
SUBMITTED TO DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WAS QUITE
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT HOW.
HOW HE PRESENTED THE INFORMATION
TO THE POLICE OFFICERS AT THE
TIME OF THE ARREST?
AS A RESULT OF GETTING THAT
INFORMATION FROM DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
THEN WE WERE ABLE TO SECURE A
DISMISSAL FOR THIS CLIENT AND BY
THE WAY SHE HERSELF WAS AN
IMMIGRANT AND BY DOING SO SHE
AVOIDED A CONVICTION FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WHICH ALLOWED
HER TO NOT BE DEPORTED AND STAY
IN THE COUNTRY WITH HER
CHILDREN.
SO I DISAGREE THAT THE THE
STATUTE AS THE BILL AS IS
CURRENTLY WORDED IS SUFFICIENT
TO PROPERLY PROTECT BUT THE
BRADY.
THE BRADY THE PROTECTIONS
AFFORDED UNDER BRADY VERSUS
MARYLAND AND I WOULD PASS I
THINK IT'S A SIMPLE. WAY TO FIX
THE STATURE AND THERE WE WOULD
OF.
.
I WITHDRAW OUR OPPOSITION AT ALL
THAT WE ARE ASKING IS JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION THAT THE BRADY
VERSUS MARYLAND DISCOVERY
PROCEDURES ARE FULLY EMPLACED.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE A QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY I'M A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS I KNOW.
THAT WERE BOTH COMMITTED TO TO
MAKING UP A LAW THAT PROTECTS TO
THE TO THE ADMISSIBILITY.
IMMIGRANTS ON ALL SIDES OF THE
LEGAL STATUS IT WILL SAY I'M TO
THE TO THE GERMAN CAME BEFORE WE
WE DID THIS BILL.
.
WITH REGARD TO TO CIVIL MATTERS
ALREADY AND IT HAS ALREADY.
CHANGE BEHAVIOR OMELET WE HAVE
PEOPLE COMING FORWARD AND ABLE
TO.
.
GO TO COURT NO WAY.
THAT PROTECTS THEIR LEGAL
RIGHTS WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY
ABOUT THEIR.
IMMIGRATION TASK BEING USED
AGAINST THEM SO THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IT'S A TOUGH WORK I
UNDERSTAND AND I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR. I'M IT'S ALWAYS EASIER
TO BE THE JOINT AUTHORED SIT
BACK WHILE THE OTHER WORK GETS
DONE.
SAW ONE APPLY THE AUTHOR AND ON
THE WORK HE'S BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF AND I
KNOW HE'LL CONTINUE. ON TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WORK
S. THAT ACCOUNT SAM I'M
DEFINITELY WILL LIVE THE BILL.
SECOND.
YOUR QUESTION.
YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK YOU SO
CHAIRMAN TOUCH WITH BROAD VERY
BRIEFLY I I WON A CLEAR
REGARDING MR HERNANDEZ'S SAW
STATEMENT WE'RE NOT IMPLYING
THAT ALL. ATTORNEYS ARE DOING US
A LARGE MAJORITY OF COLONEL
DEFENSE TURNS ARE NOT DOING THIS
IT'S I THINK IT'S IT'S REAL.
AND NOT JUST IN SAN FRANCISCO
TO LA TO BUT IT'S NOT EVERYONE
DOING AT MOST TURNS ARE NOT
DOING US.
THIS DOESN'T JUST APPLY TO THE
FACT THAT APPLIES TO THE
PROSECUTION. ARE AS WELL AS AT A
REPLIES TO EVERYONE BECAUSE
REALLY ANYONE ANY ATTORNEY COULD
BE TEMPTED. OUGHT TO DO THIS.
AND THEN IN TERMS I JUST TO BE
CLEAR TURNS THE BRADY WE DO HAVE
A STATEMENT IN THERE THAT WHEN
AND I I BELIEVE.
DURING THE SENATE PROCESS THAT
NOTHING IN THE BILL LIMITS
DISCOVERY IN A CRIMINAL ACTION
AND.
AND JUST MAKING CLEAR WHAT WAS
IMPLICIT.
AND I THINK.
WE AGREE WITH.
THE COMMITTEE THAT PUTTING AN
ACTUAL AFFIRMATIVE BRADY
OBLIGATION INTO THIS BILL JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT
OBLIGATION EXISTS.
AND FRANKLY BY PUTTING IT INTO
THE BILL IT ALMOST IMPLIES THAT
MAYBE IT DOESN'T EXIST
OTHERWISE.
AYE I THINK BRADY IS WHAT IT IS
TO BE DISCOVERED IF THERE ARE
PROBLEMS WITH THAT HAPPENING
THAT THAT'S A BROADER ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. I DON'T
THINK THIS BILL IS THE VEHICLE
TO.
TO DO THAT BUT I DO RESPECT.
THE POSITION PUBLIC DEFENDERS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
WE HAVE A.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
METRIC CALLED WORLD.
S. B. SEVENTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I
CARILLO. KALLIO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
I AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
LAST.
WHEN.
pTWENTY FOUR WE CAN GET CHANCE
TO
VOTE ON IT.
THEIR MOTION.
SECOND.
ON AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY WEBER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY I
CARILLO CANNELLA AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ LEDGER AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MR SANTIAGO.
ITEM OF SEVEN A. B. TWO THOUSAND
FIVE.
OKAY WITH THE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
BE BRIEF.
THANK YOU AB TWO THOUSAND FIVE
WOULD REINSTATE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY A TO
REPORT CHIU.
CASES OF CHILD ABUSE AND SEVERE
NEGLECTED THE DOJ'S CHILD ABUSE
A CENTRAL INDEX YOU CAN IMAGINE
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT ABLE.
AT THE PROPER LEAVE REPORT A
CHILD ABUSE CASES.
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
COUPLE WITNESSES.
YEAH WHO LIKE TO BEGIN MISTER
CHAIR BRIGHT ENOUGH WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FAIR FOREMAN
HEARING OUR FAVORITE.
WORDS MOVE THE BILL KEEP IT
VERY SHORT WE JUST WANT TO
RESTORE THIS DATABASE INTO THE
USEFUL TOOL THAT IT ONCE WAS.
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES AGENCIES.
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESS.
PORT.
ISAIAH CAPTAIN CARLES MARKETS
WITH THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT SPECIAL VICTIMS
BUREAU AND I'M JUST HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF THERE
ARE ANY AS WE PROCEED.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STAND FELIZ OUT
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S WERE CO
SPONSORING LISTEN I VOTE.
OKAY BAYLOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATHIS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LUCIA MUCH I'M HALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
LIEUTENANT SHIRLEY SO WILLIAM
SEVERED IN A SHERIFF'S ON BEHALF
OF SHERIFF MCMAHON IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
BRANCH ALONG WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
I WE RESPECTFULLY MUST OPPOSED
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE.
I DO WANT TO START BY THANKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND HIS
STAFF FOR AND ENGAGING WITH
DISCUSSIONS WITH US ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT'S DISCUSSIONS AND
HOPEFULLY.
TO RESOLVING THOSE CONCERNS.
THAT SAID.
LET ME ASK EACH OF YOU TO
IMAGINE JUST FOR A MOMENT THAT
YOU HAVE BEEN FALSELY ACCUSED OF
ABUSING A CHILD.
THIS UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT A RARE
OCCURRENCE AND NOW IT HAS
HAPPENED TO YOU.
IMAGINE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
ARRESTED AND CHARGED YOU ARE
ALSO NOTIFIED THAT YOUR NAME IS
GOING TO BE INCLUDED ON A LIST
OF PERSONS SUSPECTED OF CHILD
ABUSE. WHICH CAN BE ACCESSED BY
VARIOUS AGENCIES IN CONNECTION
WITH SOME KINDS OF LICENSING AND
EMPLOYMENT APPLICATIONS IN IN IN
ADDITION TO. INVESTIGATIONS OF
OTHER CHILD ABUSE.
YOUR CASE GOES TO TRIAL YOU ARE
NOT ONLY ACQUITTED BUT THE JUDGE
MAKES A FINDING OF FACTUAL
INNOCENCE.
YOU THEN SEEK TO HAVE YOUR NAME
REMOVED FROM THE LIST.
ONLY TO BE TOLD BY THE AGENCY
THAT INITIALLY CONDUCTED THE
INVESTIGATION THAT IT STILL
BELIEVES THE IT IT THE
ALLEGATIONS TO BE SUBSTANTIATED.
AND THAT THEREFORE YOUR NAME
WILL REMAIN ON THE LAST.
YOU HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE STIGMA
OF BEING A CUTE AN ACCUSED CHILD
ABUSER INDEFINITELY.
YOUR OPTIONS FOR WORKING IN
CHILD RELATED PROFESSIONS OR FOR
ADOPTING OR BECOMING A FOSTER
PARENT. MAY BE FORECLOSED.
THAT WAS THE SITUATION THAT
FACED MISTER AND MRS HUMPHRIES
IN THE CASE OF HUMPHRIES VERSUS
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
DECIDED BY THE NINTH CIRCUIT IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE.
WELL LAW REGARDING HOW YOU GET
ON THE CA SEE AYE INDEX AND HOW
YOU MAY BE ABLE TO GET OFF HAS
CHANGED BY THAT SINCE THEN. BUT
NOT BY THAT MUCH
THE STANDARD NOW IS THAT
ALLEGATIONS MUST BE FOUND TO BE
SUBSTANTIATED FOR A PERSON TO BE
PLACED ON THE LIST.
BUT THE CHARGES AGAINST THE
HUMPHREYS IN THAT CASE HAD BEEN
FOUND TO BE SUBSTANTIATED.
AND THE LAW NOW PROVIDES THAT A
PERSON HAS A HAS THE RIGHT TO A
HEARING TO CHALLENGE THE
LISTING.
A HEARING HELD BEFORE THE AGENCY
THAT CREATED THE LIST AND.
THE HEARING IS REQUIRED TO
SATISFY DUE PROCESS REQUIREMENTS
THAT IS THE LANGUAGE IN THE
STATUTE. WITH NO STATEMENT OF
WHAT THOSE REQUIREMENTS ARE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE CHANGES
ARE INSUFFICIENT TO PROTECT
THOSE WHO R. WRONGFULLY PUT ONTO
THAT THE CHILD ABUSE A CENTRAL
INDEX LIST FROM THE INJUSTICE OF
REMAINING ON THAT LIST WHEN THEY
HAVE BEEN WRONGLY ACCUSED.
UNDER A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
REGARDING SOCIAL SERVICES
AGENCIES MORE SPECIFIC DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS CONSIDERABLY
MARKET SPECIFIC DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS COMPARABLE NOT EQUAL
BUT COMPARABLE TO SOME OF THE
PROTECTIONS AVAILABLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ARE AVAILABLE TO PERSONS WHO ARE
PUT ON THE LIST BY THOSE SOCIAL
SERVICES AGENCIES.
BUT THOSE PROTECTIONS ARE NOT IN
THE STATUTE AND THEY WOULD NOT
BE. THEY WOULD NOT APPLY TO THE
PERSONS WHO WOULD BE LISTED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS PROPOSED
UNDER THE BILL.
NOR DO EVEN THE SETTLEMENT
PROTECTIONS GUARANTEE THAT
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN ACQUITTED
OF THE CHARGES AGAINST THEM OR
WHO HAS HAD THE CHARGES
ADJUDICATED IN IN JUVENILE COURT
PROCEEDINGS IF IF. IT INVOLVES
I'VE DEPENDENCY PROCEEDINGS THAT
THEY WERE NOT TRUE THAT THEY CAN
BE REMOVED FROM WILLISTON IN AN
EASY FASHION.
THE ACLU HAS GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT ANY GOVERNMENT DATABASE
WHERE PEOPLE CAN BE LISTED
SOLELY ON THE BASIS OF
ACCUSATIONS.
THESE CONCERNS ARE HEIGHTENED
WHERE THE STANDARDS AND
PROCEDURES FOR SUCH AS FOR
CHALLENGING SUCH A LIST LISTING
ARE NOT SPECIFIED.
FOR THESE REASONS WE BELIEVE
THAT THE POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE
FROM THE CHANGE PROPOSED IN AB
TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE GREATLY
OUT WHEN HIS THE BENEFIT AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR NOBLE.
THANK YOU EITHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OUR. FIRST OF ALL I VERY MUCH
RESPECT BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE ACLU IN THEIR POSITIONS.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AT
THIS TIME.
I WOULD APPRECIATE THE CHAIR.
ARE DISCUSSING.
Y. HE HAS MADE A A YES
RECOMMENDATION I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR HELPED MOVE
FORWARD. AND UP AND THE
COMMITTEES.
TO TALK ABOUT THE COMMITTEES
VIEW. ON.
WHAT THE PROTECTIONS ARE NOW
AND I WOULD THANK THE CHAIR VERY
MUCH FOR?
IF HE'S ABLE TO DO THAT.
YEAH I'M I'M SORRY  OKAY SO I
KNOW YOU WERE CONSULTING. THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT.
I THINK THE ACLU IS BROUGHT UPS
FIRST OF ALL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL ATTRACTED TO
BEEN MOVED HERE.
YES ARM.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ARE TO BE ABLE TO PUT THEIR
NAMES ON THE LAST.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF THE
ACLU.
I WOULD LIKE TO CHAIR I KNOW THE
COMMITTEE HAS A DIFFERENT VIEW
THAT THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAD A
DIFFERENT VIEW THAN THE ACLU.
ON.
WHAT PART WHAT PROTECTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE AND AT THE
LOFT CHAIR COULD ADDRESS THAT
NOW OR? AFTER.
THE MEMBER CLOSES AND.
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO DISCUSS.
WHAT PROTECTIONS THERE ARE FOR
PEOPLE?
GET ON THE LIST TO GET OFF THE
LIST SO THANK YOU.
WITH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ACTUAL LIKE.
D. AUTHOR OR.
OPPONENTS BUT THE THE BUILDING
GO AHEAD AND TALK ABOUT
PRODUCTION BECAUSE EVEN IF YOU
IF E PASS IT OUT OF HERE.
OF IT IS IT IS A CONCERN OF NOT
ONLY CHAIR BUT IT COMMITTEE.
ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE ON.
WHO HAD BEEN WRONGLY?
ACCUSE AND HOW TO GET THEM OFF
A.
GUY I THINK I MENTIONED EARLIER
WITH THE.
MISTER RON.
BONTA AS BILL.
WHERE IT IS A CONCERN ESPECIALLY
GANG INJUNCTIONS THAT SHE
SANTIAGO AND I ARE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH? WHERE INDIVIDUALS GET ON?
AND THEY MAY HAVE JUST DRESSED.
LIKE A GANG MEMBER AND THEY COME
FROM VERY LITTLE CLASS AFFLUENT
FAMILIES.
AND THEY GET ON THE LIST BUT
NEVER GET OFF AND I FOUND OUT
LATER WHEN YOU'RE AND TRYING TO
GO TO COLLEGE.
THAT OR WHAT WHEN THEY GET
ARRESTED FOR A TRAFFIC
VIOLATION.
THERE IS A PATTERN.
OF THEM BEING PART OF A GANG
THAT HAS.
THAT THEIR PARENTS TO KNOW ABOUT
THAT NOBODY KNEW ABOUT SO.
GETTING TO MISTER CORKS
CONCERNED AN ACL USED CONCERN
AND IT MAY NOT BE SO THAT WE
CAN.
GO THROUGH A DISCUSS NOW BUT.
IF THE BILL GETS OUT HERE MOVE
FORWARD. THAT YOU WORK WITH THE
ACLU.
TO PROVIDE THE.
ASSURANCES.
THAT THEY NEED THAT ON THIS WALL
THIS WILL CREATE MORE HARM.
ON DEM WHAT YOU TRIED TO DO.
WELL THAT WE TOOK WE TAKE THE
WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE VERY
SERIOUS AND TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE INNOCENT OR
NOT FALSELY ACCUSED.
I AND AND ALL RE ITERATE THE AIM
OF THIS LEGISLATION IS REALLY UP
TO PROTECT KIDS OF ARE
POTENTIALLY ABUSED AND SO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
ON ENSURING THAT THOSE WERE
WRONGLY ACCUSED DO NOT END UP ON
THAT LIST ABU WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE IT AT THE
IN A DAY. THERE IS A GRAVE NEED.
TO PROTECT ON CHILDREN.
FROM ABUSIVE SITUATIONS AND
THERE'S A GREAT NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE KNOW WHO THOSE PEOPLE
ARE. AND SO THE IF THEY'RE
APPLYING FOR A JOB IF THEY'RE
GOING TO BE NEAR KIDS THAT WE
PROTECT OTHER KIDS.
AS WELL AND.
AND THE WAY WE LOOK AT IT WHEN
WE ENTERED THIS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
HOW THE IN ABILITY UP TO PUT A
PERSONAL DATABASE IF THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN FACT? I
THAT THERE IS THAT THERE IS
SOMEBODY.
WHO IT WHO IS ABUSING A CHILD
OTHERS A PROCESS?
THE CASE THAT WAS STATED.
WAS IN REFERENCE TO.
TO AND TO AN INDIVIDUAL BUT
SINCE THEN THERE'S BEEN A
PROCESS PUT IN PLACE AND AND I
WOULD HAND OVER LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND I
BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE TO DOES
ELEVEN THAT WAS PUT PLACE FROM A
MISTAKE.
YOU'RE CORRECT IN AND MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D LIKE
TO REFER TO OUR CAPTAIN SPECIAL
VICTIMS BUREAU WHO KNOWS THIS
PROCESS ALL TOO WELL.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR DOING A
COUPLE MINUTES TO EXPLAIN.
JUST LIVING A BACKGROUND MYSELF
I'VE BEEN AT THE SITE SPECIAL
VICTIMS BUREAU THREE DIFFERENT
TIMES THROUGHOUT MY CAREER AND I
HAVE THIRTY YEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE MOST OF
IT WITH CHILD ABUSE CASES.
HARM YOU ARE CORRECT IN WHAT YOU
STATED AS WITH THE PROBLEM WAS
BEFORE HOWEVER IN TWENTY TWELVE
WHEN THE LAW CHANGE SO TO THE
DEFEAT XIN OF SUBSTANTIATED
CASES WHICH MADE IT. NOW ALSO
THAT IT HAS TO BE MORE LIKELY
THAN NOT THEN THE VIOLATIONS
THAT OCCUR. THAT WAS NOT THE
DEFINITION PRIOR TO THAT IN
ADDITION TO THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
HAS PUT DIFFERENT PROCEDURES IN
PLACE THAT ARE VERY SIMILAR TO
THE DEPARTMENT CHILDREN FAMILY
SERVICES AND LA COUNTY. IN THE
PROCESS THAT A PERSON WHO FEELS
THAT THEY WERE PUT IN THE
DATABASE WRONGFULLY CAN APPEAL
IT.
IF IN THAT FIRST APPEAL THEY ARE
STILL NOT SATISFIED WILL PRIOR
TO THAT OF OUR DETECTIVES IN THE
MOVING FORWARD.
CAN NOT ONLY.
SUBMIT THE CASE TO.
THE CENTRAL DATABASE BUT HAS TO
BE APPROVED BY A SUPERVISOR
BEFORE THE SUMMIT THE NAME.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ON THE
DETECTIVE SHOULDERS BUT IT ALSO
HAS A SUPERVISOR REVIEW.
ONCE A PERSON WANTS APPEAL IT IF
THEY ARE NOT HAPPY WITH THE
FIRST APPEAL WHO WILL BE DONE BY
LIEUTENANT WITHIN OUR UNIT. THEN
GOES TO OUR CAPTAIN.
WHICH CURRENTLY IS ME I WILL
THEN CONSULT NOT ONLY WITH THE.
THEIR REVIEW ALL THE CASES BUT
WILL CONSULT WITH COUNTY COUNCIL
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ON THE
SAME TERMS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSON WHO WAS PUT INTO THE
DATABASE. IS RIGHTFULLY DONE SO.
AND SO WE WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS THAT PRETTY MUCH DCFS
FOR OUR COUNTY FOLLOWS BASED ON
THE LAW. OR THE CASE THAT YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD.
I'M OKAY I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU'RE TELLING ME WHAT THE
PROCEDURE IS IN LA COUNTY. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IN THE
BILL AS REQUESTED BY THE ACLU.
THAT THERE IS A PROCEDURE. AND.
I'M GONNA RESERVE MY VOTE ON
THE FLOOR UNTIL I FIND OUT.
WHAT THE PROCEDURE IS AND MAY WE
JUST?
CAN'T RESOLVE THAT RIGHT NOW BUT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS A
UNIFORM PROCEDURE ACROSS THE
STATE NOT JUST IN LA COUNTY. AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT. IS A AS
FAIR PROCEDURE AT NIGHT I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT IS RIGHT NOW BUT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND YOU MAKE.
BUT THAT'S A CONCLUSION.
YES RESPECTFULLY ASK I VOTE. AND
SO I BUT I THINK IS IMPORTANT
THAT I SAW.
AND WE PUT DALY DIEGO ON.
AND A BASS BY BY SO DAMN.
SHAKE HIS HEAD YES WE TALKED
ABOUT COMING UP WITH SOME.
VERB IF YOU'RE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT WILL.
.
GIVE US NOT ONLY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE EXPRESSIONISTIC.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
.
SOME CONFIDENCE THAT YEARS AGO
CROSS THE BOARD.
TYPE OF UP PROCEDURES IT MAY
FOLLOW EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN LA COUNTY WHICH I HAVE A LOT
OF CONFIDENCE IN. A DEBT WE
APPRECIATED THAT WE NEED TO THE
SCENE LIKE THAT DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE LAW. AND I'D ALWAYS
SAY BETWEEN WHAT YOU ACTUALLY DO
WHEN YOU IMPLEMENTED. AND SO
LET'S TRY TO RESOLVE THAT AS IT
AS IT HOPEFULLY MOVES FOR.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
AB TWO THOUSAND BY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
I CARILLO CONGENIAL ICONS ON HIS
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO
AYE.
MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU.
NATURAL DO ANY ADD ONS BOTH VOTE
CHANGES MANUFACTURING SECTOR
PLEASE GO TO THE MAT MEASURES
TAKEN UP TODAY.
THIS INCLUDES GO.
I DON'T EVER ONE NINETEEN ELEVEN
WAS PULLED BY AUTHOR.
I DINNER TO AB NINETEEN NINETEEN
WAS TESTIMONY ONLY.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
I'D ARE NUMBER FOUR AB NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT WAS PUT BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WITH ON
CONSENT.
I DON'T EVER SIX SUNKEN FAT.
I REMEMBER SEVEN AB TWO THOUSAND
PIPE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
FOURTEEN WAS PULLED BY AUTHOR.
ITEM NUMBER NINE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN WITHOUT CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. BY MISTER BONTA LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE THIS MEASURE
WAS ON CALL AB TWENTY ONE NO
THREE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE THREE THREE ON CONSENT. AT
OUR NUMBER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SIX ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY ONE SIXTEEN
NINE CARILLO.
EARLIER I.
ITEM SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX ON CONSENT ITEM SEVENTEEN
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN A
CONSENT. ITEM EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE NINETY SEVEN ON CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN FIVE. AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY THREE HAVE BEEN SPENT
WITH. ITEM TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SEVEN WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM TWENTY ONE. AB 23-14 I WAS
A CONSENT ITEM TWENTY TWO WITH
ON CONSENT TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
ONE.
I AM TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY FIVE
A SEVEN WAS A CONSENT. ITEM
TWENTY FOUR HAS BEEN DISPENSED
WITH.
AN ITEM TWENTY FIVE HAS BEEN
DISMANTLING.
DOUBLE CHECKING.
IF YOU.
I JUST.
BUT WE GOT. THIS INCLUDES A
BUSINESS A PUBLIC SAFETY TODAY